[Musique]
messieur dam bonsoir bonsoir nous vous
recevons pour une chaîne internet qui
s'appelle Serview nous sommes en direct
est-ce que vous pouvez vous présenter
sucement analisese voigilis alors très
succintement je suis docteur en
géographie l'Institut français de
géopolitique et je suis chercheuse à
soci à de Poitier mon domaine de
spécialité c'est tout ce qui touche à la
réindustrialisation et au politiques
industrielle Maroun a Maroun aid je suis
chercheur en philosophie politique et
mon domaine de spécialité c'est la
question de l'état de la réforme de
l'État et du démantèlement des services
publics et aussi de notre industrie
bonne année bonne santé meilleur vœux
meilleur vœux à la communauté on a
décidé de commencer cette nouvelle année
sur l'industrie sur des sujets
géopolitique sur des sujets sociétaux et
les conséquences et comment s'organiser
et comment anticiper la situation parce
que l'industrie c'est aussi le sang de
notre économie et de notre pays première
question vous partagez qui est qui va
répondre en premier Anaïs qui a planté
la France ah h perd cette première
question qui a planté la France la
réponse c'est on a planté collectivement
la France en réalité je pense que si je
me restrein à mon domaine de spécialité
qui est l'industrie quand on regarde la
désindustrialisation on se rend compte
que c'est une responsabilité collective
on pourrait tenter de dire c'est les
haut fonctionnaires c'est les politiques
ou c'est les chefs d'entreprise ou c'est
notre passivité intellectuelle ou c'est
la croyance que la France et l'Europe
seraiit toujours meilleur que la Chine à
qui on a largement confié une partie de
notre production en se disant queon
pouvait spécialiser sur les tâches en
amont et en aval de la production réputé
à plus forte valeur ajoutée et que la
Chine elle ne remonterait jamais les
chaîne de valeur et se contenterit
d'être un pays site de production or on
se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui et B cette
stratégie
voir cette doctrine a été un échec mais
je pense vraiment he que la
responsabilité collective et aujourd'hui
quand on entend des politiques qui nous
disent euh la désindustrialisation il
faut réindustrialiser je pense qu'il
faut que chacun se rappelle mais ça va
aussi pour les dirigeants d'entreprise
je pourrais même dire ça va pour les
syndicats et ça va pour nos choix
individuels il faut se rappeler qui
était au manettes au moment où on a
embrasé le choix d'une économie
post-industrielle où on a fait le choix
de délocaliser massivement nos
productions pour Bénéfic et B de
produits moins cher mais pour satisfaire
nos nos désirs de consommation et
surtout laisser croire qu'on avait un
pouvoir d'achat qui en fait ne cro ne
grandissait plus tellement que ce qu'on
espéit Maroun qui a planté la France je
suis assez d'accord avec la réponse
d'anaise je pense qu'il y a eu vraiment
véritablement une mouvance idéologique
mais je pense que c'est quand même
davantage lié à un système un quelques
responsable notamment moi j'ai beaucoup
travaillé sur le rôle des des grands
corps d'état en fait en tout cas d'une
frangeche d'entre eux c'est cors à qui
on avait confié la charge de l'intérêt
général la charge de nos grandes
entreprises publiques euh et qui les ont
planté soit parce qu'elles ont fait
faillite soit parce qu'ils les ont
revendus soit parce qu'ils ont fait des
choix technologiques qui sont très
douteux mais aussi parce que comme Anaïs
le dit bien on s'est dit qu'on allait
transformer la France en un pays de Bac
+ 5 focalisé sur la conception et la RD
et que les pays asiatiques feraient le
reste euh je cite notamment Serge churou
hein qui qui lui a voulu faire cette
entreprise sans usine alors qu'il il
était à la tête d'Alcatel Alcatel
c'était quand même le numéro 1 des
télécom dans le monde à l'aube de la
révolution technologique on avait on
était un des leaders notamment des
câbles sous-marins et en fait 120000
employer et il a décidé d'en faire une
entreprise sans usine quand il a dit ça
en 2001 ça a été acclamé par tout le
monde en tout cas toute l'élite
politiofancière parisienne parce qu'on
s'est dit ah mais en fait si
l'entreprise n'a plus d'usine on aura
des meilleures marges notamment et puis
aussi l'usine n'a pas très n'a pas
beaucoup été défendu ni par la droite
évidemment ni par la gauche parce
qu'elle avait mauvaise réputation on
s'est dit on sera tous dans des métiers
plus intellectuels euh on a pêché je
dirais par naïveté parce que comme dit
Anaïs on s'est jamais dit que la Chine
allait nous rattraper aussi vite par
condescendance aussi parce qu'on pensait
qu'on était au sommet du monde et par
avidité financière parce que Serge
cherou a fait ça en fait pour améliorer
leutau de marge et finalement il a
planté Alcatel et là où je parle aussi
d'idéologie c'est que Alcatel comme il a
planté on a tout perdu et en 2015 on a
revendu la dernière vente de ce qu'on
avait d'Alcatel 29000 brevets des
décennies de recherche et développement
à Nokia et à Hua nos impôts ou pas payer
oui bah oui bien sûr en très grande
partie c'est une entreprise publique
donc payer évidemment par nos impôts
120000 postes perdu aussi et au moment
où on décide de revendre Alcatel à Nokia
il y a quand même des voix qui s'élèvent
et qui disent au ministre de l'économie
de l'époque Emmanuel Macron faites
quelque chose Emmanuel Macron dit il
faut sortir je cite de cette vision
romantique qui consiste à dire parce que
c'est une entreprise française bloquons
la fusion protégeantla et ça c'est
intéressant parce que le fait même qu'il
le disent montre aussi lui il n'y a rien
gagné à dire ça en tout cas de ce qu'on
sait mais le fait qu'ils le disent
montre l'idéologie un peu qu'il y avait
derrière et qui a un fusé partout
jusqu'à une grande majorité de la
population ouais je peutêreond dire et
apporter une précision sur ch chou parce
qu'on adore le citer comme et je suis la
première à le faire comme un peu l'image
de l'entreprise sans usine et en fait je
crois qu'il faut aussi rappeler qu'on
était vraiment dans une doctrine
économique qui était principalement
anglo-saxon sur cette idée d'aller
modulariser l'économie et les activités
des entreprises on se disant on peut
finalement garder des tâches dans
certains pays confier d'autres tâches à
d'autres pays et en fait il y a
énormément d'entreprises américaines qui
ont choisi le même chemin dès les années
80 c'est une entreprise comme IBM qui
délocalise et qui va confier finalement
certaines activités à des fabricants
asiatiques et c'est comme ça qu'on a un
TSMC par exemple à Taiwan qui émerge
dans la production semiconducteur et qui
devient le le leader mondial c'est comme
ça qu'on a si on prend d'autres exemples
des Shimano qui sont leaders dans la
production de pièces à destination du du
vélo et donc ça ça c'est vraiment une
stratégie économique qui est connue à
partir des années 80 notamment après de
grands groupe américain et qui a inspiré
Alcatel et Alcatel on dit là finalement
on dit Serge tou à la par parentalité
pardon des entreprises sans usine mais
on trouve plein d'exemples d'autres
entreprises un groupe comme Nike il
s'est fondé sur l'idée que la production
était confiée à d'autres et donc
finalement j'ai envie de dire que même
dans cette idée là où on se dit c'était
une idéologie qui nous a imprimer ou une
doctrine économique c'est même pas
tellement une doctrine française c'est
pas un choix français on s'est laissé
imprégner on peut retrouver des extrait
de de de d'articles de cabinet de
conseil qui dans les années 2000 disait
si vous gardez votre production en
France en fait vous êtes condamné à
périclité donc il faut la délocaliser
soit à l'est de l'Europe soit en Asie là
où les coûts salariaux sont moins
importants alors imprégné ça veut dire
influencer ça veut dire de l'ingérence
ça veut dire on s'est fait avoir on
avait pas notre intégrité de pensée on
l'a fait par facilité est-ce qu'on a
perdu cet esprit d'entrepreneuriat
français et cet esprit de robustesse et
de résilience
française qui nous a imprégné
anaïise alors c'est l'école de Chicago
c'est des pense que je pense que sur les
ingérencesê que mar a une meilleure
réponse que que la mienne parce qu'il a
sûement peut-être plus étudié le sujet
mais je pense qu'il y a une il y a il y
a un un un livre enfin il y a Nicolas
dUFC qui est le patron de la BPI la
banque publique d'investissement qui a
écrit un livre sur la
désindustrialisation et qui allait
interroger des dirigeants qui ont connu
cette vague de désindustrialisation il
explique quelque chose qui moi me semble
très juste il dit si vous voulez
convaincre la France d'une idée il
suffit de prendre
Paris en Allemagne il faut prendre un
plus plus que Berlin pour arriver à
faire changer le mode de penser des des
Allemands Bour pas que Enour on va pas
faire toutes les villes allemandes sinon
on va voir à quel point je suis une
géographe désastreuse et on ne
questionnera pas ce soir sur les
départements français parce que je pense
que les Land allemand peut-être
non peut-être les Landes et peut-être
les villages et villes et là non mais en
tout cas le tissu industriel allemand et
la la culture allemande et la structure
du capital allemand et la manière dont
l'Allemagne s'est constituée en tant que
nation n'est pas la même histoire que la
France et en France on voit bien qu'on
est très on a un côté très centralisé et
tout se gère à Paris et tout se gère
entre quelques alors quelques personnes
sans vouloir tomber dans un truc
complotiste mais quand on c'est quoi un
truc complotiste non mais un truc je
veux dire je veux pas alimenter l'idée
qui suffirer qu' a quelques que quelques
personnes dominent le pays mais on se
rend compte qu'il y a quand même une
proximité des élites le la proximité
entre les grands corps d'état et les
grands dirigeants d'entreprise avec des
allers-retours entre le public et le le
privé fait que il y a un certain
transfert de enfin de ne me déconcentre
pas s'il te plaît un certain transfert
de de de de compétenence en tout cas il
y a il y a une promiscuité et il y a
sûrement l'idée que c'était un le le
choix c'était cette le le seul choix
qu'on avait c'était le fait de de
confier notre production ailleurs mais
qui en même temps a pas été vraiment un
choix parce que on n pas fait pleinement
le choix de l'économie de service comme
l'a fait le Royaume-Uni ou de la tech
comme l'ont fait les États-Unis on fait
un choix hybride et au final qu'est-ce
qui n reste de tout ça on n'est pas on
n'est pas vraiment une puissance une
place financière même si on profite un
peu du brexit mais on n'est pas une
grande place financière on est puissance
moy puissance mais est-ce queon est on
est oui on est on est on est une
puissance moyenne mais c'est quoi notre
puissance aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui fait
la puissance de la France qu'est-ce qui
fait son rayonnement à l'international
et j'ai envie de dire et là je vais être
un peu provoque qui est-ce qui respecte
encore la France à l'échelle
internationale à part les Français bien
entendu qui en sont très fiers et je
pense que la France représente encore
quelque chose à l'international dans le
cœur des individus des citoyens de
chaque pays mais il y a aussi énormément
de pays aujourd'hui où la France n'a
plus le droit de n'a plus le droit de
citer et tout ça est le fait de notre de
notre inconséquence de notre manque de
vision stratégique on peut en parler sur
le plan industriel on pourit parler sur
plein d'autres sujets alors on va
commencer à faire un peu je vais je vais
renvoyer sur sur Maroun on va on fera le
constat de où on en est maintenant des
défaillances des perspectives ça va être
pas à piquer des anon mar est-ce qu'on
nous a tordu le bras tordu le cou tordu
l'oreille tordu le Atlas axis pour nous
faire avaler cette société de on n pas
d'usine on produit chez les autres on a
que des balles + 5 on a une industrie de
service et puis on va être les meilleurs
dans la chatch est-ce qu'il y avait pas
un petit peu un
terro comment formuler ça est-ce que il
y a pas eu une erreur éducative de notre
système éducatif pour former des gens
plus robustes à des influences
extérieures et plus je dirais un mot qui
est devenu sale dans dans la bouche de
certains est-ce qu'on n pas élevé
suffisamment de patriotes je ne dis pas
nationaliste je dis est-ce qu'on a pas
élevé suffisamment de patriotes pour
être les vigilants du Cap que la la
France était en train de prendre tout à
fait je pense que je rebondis sur la
question de l'influence combien c'est
plus facile d'influencer la France je
retrace dans mon livre l'histoire
notamment de la haute fonction publique
et Liv la destruction de
l'État bouquin et de et de Lena en
particulier où je montre bien comment en
fait dans les années euh avant l'ENA
dans disons dans les années 1930 vous
aviez des concours des recrutements par
ministère et donc vous aviez les
ingénieurs des corps et euh le corps des
Ponts et Chaussées le corps des Eaux et
Forêts et cetera avec des cultures
différentes euh qui arrivaient au sommet
de l'État déjà l'ENA a été dangereux
parce que ça a constitué un goulot
d'étranglement par lequel il faut passer
pour arriver au pouvoir donc vous voyez
bien que c'est beaucoup plus facile de
convaincre 40 personnes dans une promo
que euh différents ha fonctionnaires qui
viennent d'horizons différents
et puis je retrace aussi la différence
dans le concours de l'ENNA c'est
intéressant la première Enna créée par
Charles de Gaul vous avez des concours
vous avez des épreuves d'histoire de
géographie de rhtorique sur un homme
d'État qui a pu vous inspirer
progressivement l'enas est devenu des
épreuves simplement de finances publiqu
de droits européens d'éloquence de plus
de contrôle la dialectique oui le
dialectique mais si vous voulez la la
forme plus que plus que le fond parceque
Lena aussi 80 % ont finit par venir de
sciencep et donc vous avez une
uniformisation des parcours de la L1 en
fait jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de l'enat et
puis ces personnes-là vont être
parachuté directement au pouvoir en
pensant souvent exactement la même chos
et donc il suffit qu'une mode
idéologique imprègne le tout Paris en
tout cas son élite
politico-financière pour qu'elle soit
imposée à tous et au moment des
entrepris sans unit effectivement le le
fablesse dont on parle c'est intéressant
parce que vous aviez les chefs
d'entreprise qui en parlaient mais qui
étaient sur les mêmes bans d'écoles que
les ha fonctiontionnaire de Bery de
l'époque fabless ça veut dire sans usine
fablesse exactement c'est ce que disait
Anaïs c'est que ça vient des États-Unis
vous aviez Alain Madelin par exemple qui
disait il faut que la France devienne un
pays de siège de sièges sociaux
et je parle à haut fonctionnaire
quiinterroge qui lui dit oui mais
l'impact économique il disait ça va rien
changer à notre balance commerciale
parce que on va produire ailleurs et
rapatrier les dividendes mais sauf que
vous avez plus les emplois vous avez
plus la production chez vous et puis si
un jour on décide de fermer de toute
façon vous aurez plus les dividendes
vous allez devoir vendre les les
entreprises on aura plus le savoir faire
et on aura plus le savoirfaire
exactement et et et vous voyez aussi le
mépris si vous voulez pour les
conséquences sociales parce que derrière
d'accord vous avez une vision purement
macroéconomique mais enfin les gens les
territoires ça fait des territoires
entiers oùù on ferme les usines et donc
c'était et je retrace notamment certains
parcours mais c'est pas pour les citer
eux mais dans mon livre de personnes qui
ont pu être dans les commissions de
l'État et puis juste après passer dans
les entreprises qu'ils étaient censé
réglementer et puis faire un tour chez
Lazar et puis revenir j'en cite même
certains qui était à la fois partenire
chez mckinse et au fonctionnaire en même
temps il fut des époques où ils ont leur
déontologie leur dev de réserve
qu'est-ce que c'est que cette pensée il
faut être bienveillant avec ces gens-là
qui font des allers-retours public privé
il ils peuvent penser que c'est bien
c'est-à-dire que si vous vous entourez
simplement de personnes qui pensent
ainsi si vous avez personne pour vous
contredire si vous avez même été
sélectionné à ça et c'est là où je
montre aussi la perversité et si vous
voulez le danger du système français qui
s'est retourné contre lui-même parce que
il créent une noblesse d'État par les
diplômes donc des gens qui ont
l'assurance parce qu'ils ont fait
Polytechnique parce qu'ils ont fait et
donc ils se disent j'ai été reçu parce
que j'ai pensé comme ça on apprend à ne
pas penser différemment on s'entoure de
de gens pareils et donc derrière c'est
des milieux extrêmement homog risque
d'être en silo en en vasclou je dirais
même en consanguinité d'opinion quels
sont les risques en terme de prospective
c'est on devient borne on devient
aveugle on devient facilement cornacable
on vient
parissous on a peut-être même parfois
pas accès aux données euh aux
conséquences de ce qu'on fait euh par
exemple j'avais travaillé en partenar
avec le cabinet de l'éducation nationale
on parlait du lycée professionnel euh
moi à l'époque j'enseignais en lycée
professionnel on ne parlait pas du même
objet ça veut dire que eux parlaient du
lycée pro puis moi là je leur apporte un
quelque chose que tous les profs de
lycée pro voient c'est-à-dire que
aujourd'hui la plupart des filières du
lycée professionnel on a fermé les
filières les plus insérantes parce qu'il
y avait besoin d'investir dans des
machines donc on a fermé les filières
industrielles et artisanales et on a
surtout ouvert des filière du tertière
administratif et aujourd'hui au lycée
pro la filière où vous avez le plus de
formation c'est les secrétariats et
daactilo or il y a plus de dactilo en
France donc vous devez vendre à vos
élèves qui doivent travailler pour un
déboucher où vous savez que de toute
façon ils seront au chômage à environ 40
pardon 50 à 60 % l'intelligence
artificielle là-dessus alors
effectivement alors même que si jamais
vous les formez pour des métiers qui
sont plus industriel plus plus
artisanaux au contraire je pense qu'il y
a encore des perspectives j'aborde ça au
ministère ils étaient même pas au
courant ça veut dire que et aujourd'hui
vous avez un développement d'un système
à deux vitesses en France dans lesquel
les décideurs sont indépendants euh des
conséquences de leur réforme parce
qu'ils vont aller se soigner à l'hôpital
américain parce qu'ils se soignent dans
les cliniques privées parce qu'ils vont
dans les lycées bilingues des
centres-villees et derrière à
l'université ils vont aux États-Unis ou
en Angleterre faire des bachelors pour
leurs enfants et donc ils ne sont pas
soumis aux conséquences euh de leur
propres mesurees personne autour d'eux
n'y est nécessairement soumis et donc
c'est une forme d'aveuglement où en fait
ils peuvent continuer à faire avec les
slogans qui pensent fonctionnent euh
d'autant plus qu'il peut y avoir des
personnes malintentionnées notamment des
lobbyistes qui leur disent que c'est
effectivement ce qu'il faut faire des
États ou d'autres États ou d'autres
puissances effectivement euh l' exemple
l'exemple par exemple le programme
nucléaire français les Allemands qui
font des croches pates à la France par
exemple le programme nucléaire français
euh les Allemands ont quasiment ça tu
connais bien mais dans la la taxonomie
verte à nous convaincre que le gaz était
vert euh parce que c'est du gaz naturel
et le nucléaire ne l'était pas n était
plus polluant alors que bon
scientifiquement quand même le gaz aimit
plus de CO2 que le que le nucléaire ils
nous ont aussi convaincu
de si vous voulez de prendre tout un
ensemble de règles qui vont Lester EDF
d'un poids très important accroître la
dette aussi de DF voire même accélérer
l'arrêt ou en tout cas la mise en
difficulté de la filière nucléaire
française alors même que on en avait
besoin Alstom Alstom
évidemmentch Alstom technique Alcatel
Areva Péchin toutes ces défaites
industrielles où on nous a convaincu que
c'était plus ou moins une bonne chose de
défaite ou c'est un
braquage je dirais que c'est une défaite
quand on a fait faillite à cause d'un
endettement excessif vivindi Alcatel
técom Areva nucléaire c'est plutôt un
braquage quand on a vendu des choses qui
fonctionnaient très bien Atos Péchin aos
un peu des deux un peu des deux pouros
c'est un bon gestionnaire non ah thry
breton il est très fort parce que il a
réussi qui tout seul à plus ou moins
mettre en grande difficulté France
Télécom vous êtes sûr ça c'est lui qui a
fait ça ou c'est la conjoncture Bull
Thomson France tellécom Athos parce que
et là on revient sur l'influence aussi
au niveau des élite politico-financière
parisienne c'était de Bonon au tournant
des années 2000 d'être le grand patron
qui allait faire le plus d'acquisition
et donc pour acquérir plein de trucs il
faut s'endetter et donc vous devez
endetter votre entreprise pour acheter
plein d'autres entreprises euh le
président de vivindi de l'époque
Jean-Marie Messier ça s'appelait La
Compagnie Générale des Eaux il s'est mis
à racheter beaucoup parce que aussi vous
percevez des commissions vos amis
perçoivent des commissions et cetera
c'est de la suputation ou c'est c'est
c'est de c'est de notoriété publique
qu'on prend un petit peu ah non non
c'est comme çaut comme ça que ça
fonctionne ça veut dire que il peut
avoir des bonus qui sont indexés à
certains résultats de son entreprise
évidemment si vous achetez une
entreprise peut-être une croissance plus
rapide les banques d'affaires si jamais
il y a une transaction elles vont
toucher 1 %. si vous faites une
transaction à 1 milliard ellees touche
millions hein c'est d'ailleurs pour
Alstom par exemple pour la transac c'est
fiscalisé ça dépend où vous êtes basé
mais ça dépend où c'est transféré oui
c'est ça Anaïs on en est où là le tissu
industriel français il prend quelle
tournure le constat c'est on par à la
guerre bientôt on est dans quelles
conditions
ouis alors mauvaise mais peut-être une
je je mettrais un une une nuance sur
J'irais pas chercher forc il y a
des des peut-être des puissances
étrangères qui sont qui ont une
responsabilité dans notre d routes mais
on n pas besoin des autres pour se tirer
une ballle dans le pied c'est-à-dire que
ce qu'on oublie de voir c'est que
peut-être que la France cherche toujours
des amis eu la réalité c'est que en
politique ou dans les nations on n pas
des ennemis on on on a pas d'ennemis on
a pas d'emis on a pas d'ennemis on a des
alignements des désalignements d'intérêt
et ça on a beaucoup de mal à le
comprendre que nos intérêts ne sont pas
for on les les dirigeants les les
dirigeants politiques en tout cas et
peut-être aussi on retrouve cette idée
dans dans l'administration mais l'idée
est que l'Allemagne elle défend les
intérêts de l'industrie allemande elle
défend l'intérêt des Allemands et elle
ne défend pas les intérêts des Français
et elle se sert de l'Union
européenne je pense pas que non alors
non elle ne sert pas les intérêts des
Européens puisque il y a il y a un
désalignement globalement des intérêts
entre les 27 les 27 états- membres les
intérêts de la France ne sont pas les
intérêts de l'Allemagne comme les
intérêts des Pays-Bas ne sont pas les
intérêts des des Français peut-être un
peu plus alignés avec les intérêts
allemands et ce désalignement d'intérêt
ça conduit à quoi et B à accepter de
conduire des rapports de force au sein
de l'Union européenne de questionner
parfois aussi ce que sont les équilibres
industriel au sein de l'Europe
l'Allemagne son premier ses premiers
partenaires commerciaux restent des pays
européens et après elle commerce
énormément avec la Chine elle est pas
dans une situation de balance
commerciale comme nous et ça m'amène à
la situation de l'industrie française
qui aujourd'hui est
euh je je je dirais pas jusqu'à
catastrophique mais en tout cas on est
le pays le plus désindustrialisé euh de
la de la zone euro alors on va me
trouver des contreexemples comme le
Luxembourg ou aut qui étit pas forcément
des grandes puissances industrielles euh
le poids de l'industrie dans le PIB
français aujourd'hui c'est environ 10
points de PIB contre 19 en Allemagne
l'industrie manufacturière 19 en
Allemagne 15 en Italie 15 en moyenne
européenne en 90 c'était combien en 90
pour la France c'est environ 16 % et 25
% pour l'Allemagne donc il y a ce qu'on
voit c'est qu'il y a une une
désindustrialisation qui se fait quand
même dans tous les pays européens mais
la désindustrialisation on peut la
questionner c'est-à-dire que par exemple
le on ne peut pas considérer le le
l'industrie la santé de l'industrie
uniquement au regard du poids de
l'industrie dans le PIB pourquoi parce
que on peut très bien avoir une
industrie qui croit mais d'autres
secteurs qui vont croître plus vite et
donc infin l'industrie stagne voir
régresse un peu dans son poids dans le
PIB mais finalement elle se développe et
donc on peut regarder un autre
indicateur qui va être par exemple la
valeur ajoutée de l'industrie
manufacturière et comment elle progresse
et si on regarde sur la période 2002
2023 on se rend compte que la valeur
ajoutée française dans l'industrie
manufacturière elle progresse elle
augmente de 16 % contre 40 % en
Allemagne mais 2 % en Italie donc ce que
ça veut dire c'est que l'industrie
manufacturière même si on a une
contraction à à certains égards en terme
de valeur Contin continu à progresser
mais les autres secteurs de l'économie
ont continué à progresser plus vite
qu'ell donc il y a une stagnation voir
une ression dans dans le PIB maintenant
si je regarde d'autres indicateurs comme
la niveau de production de l'industrie
ben on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui on
est revenu au niveau de production enfin
2023 on est revenu au niveau de
production de 2019 en valeur pas en
volume c'est-à-dire que nos sites
industrielles ne sont pas complètement
saturé on est on crée de l'emploi sur la
période 2017-2023 donc en 2023 on a créé
entre 2007 et 2023 on crée 100000
emplois donc on revient au niveau
d'emploi en 2023 de 2013 ces 100000
emplois ils ont été subventionnés à
hauteur de combien d'argent public parce
que si j'injecte 10 € et que j'en
récupère qu'un seul c'est c'est
compliqué ça j'ai pas le le le le le le
le matrix exactement en tête mais je
pourrais le rechercher le le on le
recommuniquer par la suite milliard 1000
milliards pendant 7 ans j'achète la paie
sociale en France ouais alors mais de
toute manière je je true mes chiffres on
peut se dire que les emplois qui ont été
créés en fait il y a il y a on peut se
dire que certains emplois sont cré dans
des activités qui ont pas forcément été
subventionnées et que les activités qui
ont été fortement subventionnées ne sont
pas forcément celles qui créent de
l'emploi je prends l'exemple de la
filière automobile très fortement aidé
dans le cadre du plan de relance euh
pour autant on voit qu'il y a une casse
dans cette filière notamment qu' y a la
transition de véhicule thermique versus
le V enfin vers le véhicule électrique
et avec des problèmes d'anticipation et
cetera ceci choc énergétique et de choc
énergétique et ça c'est pour compléter
le tableau ceci dit quand on dit je crée
100000 emplois je reviens au niveau 2013
après en avoir détruit entre 200 et 3
millions depuis les années 70 euh je
crée de l'emploi dans un contexte où ma
production industrielle stagme stagne en
terme de volume c'est-à-dire que j'ai un
problème de productivité je crée de
l'emploi sans forcément générer plus
d'activité donc tout ça a fait que la
situation de l'industrie elle est euh
mauvaise que à cela s'ajoute une crise
énergétique h on a eu une une une
période 2020 ou 2023 on s'est dit ça y
est la euh 2020 2023 ça y est la
réindustrialisation commence et en fait
on se rend compte qu'on avait juste
arrêtter la désindustrialisation mais
qu'on était plutôt en une situation de
stagnation et la crise énergétique en
2022 elle est venue bouleverser les
choseson a on a réussi à à mortir un peu
près certains certains certains chocs
très temporairement et que là
aujourd'hui on voit que c'est la
débandade il a 66000 défaillances
d'entreprises en 2024 2025 va être une
année noire c'est toutes les filières
industrielles qui sont touchées il y a
des défaillances d'entreprises dans tous
les territoires et le problème c'est
quand on a une défaillance d'entreprise
on peut se dire c'est qu'une entreprise
mais je vais toucher euh les emplois
chez les sous-traitants euh qui chez mes
sous-traitants chez mes fournisseurs des
emplois induits c'est-à-dire qui sont
liés à la consommation à la fiscalité de
ses emplois direct et indirect et donc
globalement et bien je peux avoir des
territoires qui vont rentrer en crise
comme on l'a connu et à partir de
là ce qui est ce qui est ce qui est
terrible c'est que si on est sur un
territoire comme la région parisienne on
il y a un dynamisme économie qui fait
que les les on va recréer des emplois
par ailleurs il y a certains territoires
où l'activité des dépend de ce site
industriel et à partir du moment où on
dit et ben on génère moins de fiscalité
ça va être et les gens vont déménager ça
va être moins de service public moins de
commerce un prix de l'immobilier qui va
baisser donc des gens qui ont pu
s'endetter pour acheter un bien vont se
retrouver vraiment avec un système de
paupérisation pas la la sûreté de
retrouver de l'emploi et cetera et ça et
ça crée un
cerclepressif qui est d'autant plus
inquiétant qu'aujourd'hui que la France
n'est pas le seul pays en situation
industrielle périlleuse l'Allemagne
connaît une situation de
désindustrialisation depuis 2016 elle a
détruit entre 2017 et 2023 en CR 3 %
d'emploi industriel l'Allemagne en
détruit 1 % elle ferme des sites
industriels quand nous en créons et ça
n'est que le début puisque l'Allemagne
était très dépendante du gaz russe elle
est toujours elle est toujours et donc
elle est confrontée à un phénomène de
transition très rapide qu'elle ne ne
sa'est pas affrontter des grands groupes
industriels allemands qui commencent à
se dire je vais tourner le dos à
l'Allemagne pour aller m'implanter aux
États-Unis avec les aides mises en place
dans le cadre de la loi de de réduction
de l'inflation euh l'autre point l'autre
l'autre point faible de l'industrie
allemande c'est que son moteur c'était
les exportations tournit principalement
vers la Chine qu'est-ce qui est en train
de se qu'est-ce qu' est en train de se
passer la Chine achète des véhicules
électriques fabriqués en Chine a remonté
les chaînes de valeur sur la machine
outil et se dit aujourd'hui j'ai une
demande faible en Chine j'ai une
surcapacité de production le marché
américain est en train de se fermer à
moi je cherche des nouveaux débouchés et
le débouché c'est l'Europe avec une une
guerre des prix qui est phénoménale
aujourd'hui pourquoi les industries
françaises et européennes vont mal
pourquoi on a un risque systémique pour
l'industrie européenne et pourquoi on
risque de ne plus avoir la capacité dans
les 10 à 20 ans à venir de dessiner
c'est même pas se redresser décider
notre soué c'est décider notre destin en
fait qu'est-ce qu'on veut faire comment
on veut préser parce que ce qui est en
train de se jouer hein tout simplement
c'est avoir les moyens de financer notre
modèle social avoir le moyen de financer
ce que nous avons envie de faire et le
projet de de société qu'on veut
construire avoir le moyen de préserver
des valeurs dans lesquelles on croit et
une valeur ça pourrait être la liberté
aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
très différente l'Allemagne a pas le
niveau de dette de la France l'Allemagne
elle peut décider encore d'injecter
plusieurs milliards d'euros dans son
économie pour l'adresser5 % de
d'endettement ils sont à combien les
Allemands euh qui à 65 les Allemands les
Allemands il sont environ
60 60 60 6 les Français sont à combien
115 110 et là vous comptez les retraites
alors non mais parce queon les retraites
on les retrait c'est vrai sujet qui est
lié à la question industrielle et
d'ailleurs je passe du coocalan donc
c'est un peu décousu mais il y a une
question moi que j'aurais trouvé
intéressante et ça va faire merci je
l'ai pas posé criser tout le monde euh
dans je pense que c'est c'est une vraie
question polémique il y a un truc qu'on
dit dans l'industrie c'est le serpent de
mer si on veut réindustrialiser il faut
mobiliser la les capitaux des Français
parce que lespargne des Français ell
dort sur des comptes et cetera il y a
deux choses deux choses je ve qu'on
qu'il faut qu'on a en tête parce que là
ça nous renvoie vraiment à notre
responsabilité collective l'épargne des
Français aujourd'hui elle va financer
quelle économie américaine avec les
fonds de retraite exactement et la
question la question et les produits
l'épargne salarial aujourd'hui qu'est-ce
qui intéresse les gestionnaires
d'épargne salarial et français c'est
d'avoir des produits avec le maximum de
de de de participation américaine parce
que c'est là où les tri se font parce
que au final au bout de la journée tout
le monde se dit qu'est-ce que je veux
c'est assurer que mon argent permettre
de gagner un peu plus un peu plus
d'argent même si on est sur de l'épargne
salarial même si on critique le
capitalisme
je simplifie donc ça c'était mobiliser
leséparn des Français il y avait un
moment où la question devait se poser à
travers la question des fonds de pension
c'était au moment de la réforme des
retraites c'est est-ce qu'on accepit
d'aller mobiliser l'épargne des Français
au service de notre économie en en
intégrant le sujet de la retraite par
capitalisation et c'est un un débat qui
est qui est qui est douloureux mais à un
moment si on veut mobiliser l'épargne
des Français et qui est en plus
douloureux parce que c'est la question
de comment est-ce que on finance les
retraites des générations futures tout
en ayant à financer les retraites là et
donc la question qui va se reposer méc
unement à nous c'est la question de la
dette et notre niveau d'endettement et
comment on gère on gère tout ça mais si
on veut mobiliser l'épargne des des des
Français en faveur de l'économie
française il y a pas 36000 manières de
le faire alors après on peut faire des
fonds régionaux on peut mettre des
dispositifs pour inciter les gens à
investir directement dans une entreprise
mais quand vous êtes monsieur madame
tout le monde et que vous avez juste
envie de pas vous appauvrir vous avez
besoin de gens qui vous qui ceux qui
gèrent votre épargne le fassent en
faveur de l'économie française vous
allez pas investir tout seul dans des
dans des entreprises sans savoir dire il
faut savoir lire un un business plan
faire confiance au il y a trop de choses
qui sont compxes juste une question un
peu madame tout le monde on on j'entends
mobiliser mon épargne et je vais
réfléchir comme monsieur et madame tout
le monde quand vous avez vu cette bande
de
branquignol de branque mais à tous les
étages mais moi j'ai pas envie de leur
confier mon poillon ils vont faire ils
vont faire de la bouie avec B
désolé
maoun effectivement je pense que là où
si jamais il y a des fonds de pension il
faut que ça soit très encadré la
question c'est de savoir à qui est-ce
qu'on les confie je pense qu'on a déjà
il y a déjà certaines structures comme
la VP France notamment qu'on avait
créétait avant c'était quoi c'était
France avant non c'était oo c'était plus
de trois structures oui qui ont qui ont
pu fusionner je pense qu'elles sont nées
avec le fait pour pour pour revenir un
peu en amont sur la question justement
de la perte des maîtrises des capitaux
je pense que et les branquignol aussi ça
m'intéresse et les
branquignol le le premier point c'est
que effectivement on parle beaucoup de
la désindustrialisation moi j'appelle
désindustrialisation par le bas
c'est-à-dire le fait que on met nos
usines et nos capacités productives
ailleurs il y a aussi la
désindustrialisation par le haut ça veut
dire qu'on perd la maîtrise des capitaux
et ça ça c'est un point clé parce que
c'est à partir de là on n'est plus
maître de notre propre destin on parle
beaucoup et vous allez là à nouveau
avoir dans les médias les le C40 a fait
100 milliards de bénéfices encore cette
année reversé en dividende l'économie va
bien oui en fait ce qu'on oublie de dire
c'est que aujourd'hui le C40 est
majoritairement possédé par des
actionnaires étrangers et donc c'est de
l'argent qui va sortir qui va sortir de
France c'est aussi le fait que la prise
de décision ne se fait plus forcément en
France on voit très bien par exemple
quand Patrick pouyanet avait été
auditionné à l'Assemblée nationale on
lui a dit oui mais la total vient de
faire 20 milliards de profit net cette
année 20 milliards hein donc quand on
rapporte au déficit des retraites on
c'est quand même voilà 20 milliards qui
sont sortis de l'État à l'époque les
pétroliers étaient des entreprises
publiques et là le député lui dit
Monsieur pouyané pourquoi vous ne
réinvestissez pas ça dans la transition
écologique Patrick pouanet il est bien
parce que il est très direct très
honnête il dit c'est un choix de gain il
dit parce que je ne travaille pas pour
vous je travaille pour mes actionnaires
si vous voulez investir c'est à vous de
le faire et il a raison ça veut dire que
effectivement le principal actionnaire
de Total aujourd'hui c'est Black Rock
notamment mais aussi d'autres fonds
d'autres fonds américains il y a
certains grands investisseurstit
français comme Amundi enfin c'est un peu
la même logique et donc derrière ça ne
se décide plus chez vous et qu'est-ce
qui est en train de se passer
aujourd'hui si on valisation de la
France au profit des États-Unis oui mais
pas que des États-Unis mais disons la
vassalisation comme le comme le disait
Anaïs on peut pas en vouloir aux autres
pays d'en profiter on peut pas en
vouloir aux autres pays de remplir le
vide de pouvoir chez nous quand vous
retirez votre état forcément ça va être
rempli par d'autres personnes et et on
le voit très bien aujourd'hui vous allez
voir aussi dans les titres des journaux
de plus en plus là je lisais dans les
échos ce matin Goldman sax qui nous dit
n'investissez pas dans le CAC40 ce sont
de mauvais placements investissez dans
les valeurs américaines oui d'accord
mais enfin Goldman sax a quand même des
intérêts à dire ça les intérêts à dire
ça c'est que tout l'argent va aller aux
États-Unis nos valeurs vont continuer à
à à descendre alors même qu'on a
d'excellentes entreprises et ces
excellentes entreprises vont pouvoir
être racheté pour une bouchée de pain
par les Américains donc c'est ça semble
évident et pourtant et pourtant et c'est
là où vous voyez que c'est aussi c'est
au niveau des des de la prise de
conscience c'est au niveau des mental
merci à Ren Montebourg on pour la pour
la prise de conscience effectivement et
et pour les personnes qui disent mais
attendez on est en train de se faire
avoir comme des Bleus c'est pas la faute
des États-Unis qui eux évidemment bah il
ils en profitent mais il faut qu'on
sache se défendre intellectuellement sur
ce pointlà pour revenir à la question de
branquignol de des branquignoles et de
l'épargne les branquignoles c'est aussi
lié au fait que déjà pourquoi
branquignol pas d'anticipation c'est
vous qui avez utilisé le terme moi je
connais pas déf pr tout suitené quignol
là on est chaud pour 2025 là on commence
à on va se fâcher cette année pourquoi
les branquignoles ils ont rien anticipé
aucune mesure proactive aucun scénario
pour se protéger on laisse la France
ouverte au désossages numéro 1 c'est le
courttermisme alors c'est quoi le
courtermisme c'est ma carrière mon petit
chef mon petit pogon ma petite
commission ma petite placeage chaude oh
ils y gagent pas forcément quelque chose
je reprends total par exemple et
alfakiten c'était les principales
entreprises pétrolières françaises
possédé majoritairement par l'État pour
les deux et puis dans les années 1990 on
les a privatisé à trois reprises
différentes pourquoi on les a privatisé
bah notamment parce qu'il y avait un
déficit annuel il fallait réduire le
déficit annuel quelqu'un proposait de
les racheté pour une valorisation enfin
cétait en 50 millions de francs de
francs alors qu'aujourd'hui ça rapporte
20 milliards par an de bénéfice net donc
vous voyez le manque à gagné
considérable sur 30 ans qui s'est fait
du fric là-dedans
toujours les intermédiaires toujours les
personnes qui vous orchestrre on les n
enfin est-ce qu'on est capable de les
remonter bah si vous voulez derrière
c'est les personnes qui vont vous prenez
Alstom par exemple Arna mtebourg il cite
bien les personnes et Arna mtebourg
explique que dans le cas d'Alstom c'est
le fait que des gens aient pu toucher
des commissions qui a pu justifier la
vente parce que je répète les
intermédiaires touchent entre 1 2 ou 3 %
du montant de la vente si vous vendez
quelque chose à à 10 milliards ils vont
se répartir 300 400 milli
et donc Arnaud mbourg dit Alstom je n'ai
rien pu faire tout Paris avait été loué
qui est tout Paris bah les banques
d'affaires les cabinets de conseil les
cabinets d'avocat les cabinets de
communication business normal business
normal c'est et on peut pas en vouloir à
une entreprise normale de vouloirouir
maintenant parce que quand ça touche aux
intérêts c'est à l'état de dire non de
Gaulle savait stopper et on allait en
1963 il y avait une industrie
stratégique je je m'excuse j'ai oublié
le secteur qui allait être vendu aux
Italiens et aux Allemands il a dit
celle-là non en 2003 en 63 par par en
2003 quand on veut vendre péchinet et
Lazar était derrière et ben on a juste
vendu péchinet leader mondial
d'aluminium tout le monde a laissé faire
donc c'est au pouvoir politique aussi de
dire je pense il y a deux trois trucs un
qui alors les Allemands ils sont
toujoursés mais c'est un truc
intéressant en Allemagne c'est la
structure du capital des entreprises
allemandes qui sont principalement des
familyes office avec des banques
régionales qui prennent les
participation en capital et donc ça
limite aussi peut-être certaines
évasions et le fait que la base
industrielle allemande soit rester
solide il y a des grandes familles qui
investissent dans l'industrie allemande
ce qui est peut-être moins le cas dans
l'industrie française la deuxième chose
c'est que si on compare l'Allemagne et
la France ou même l'Allemagne la France
et l'Italie c'est sur les les types
d'entreprises que nous avons en France
on est un pays de grand groupe et le
fait qu'on soit un pays de grand groupe
c'est aussi l'héritage golop pompidolien
on voulait avoir des grandes entreprises
au service de filière qui contribuent à
l'indépendance à la renommée de la
France or ces grands groupes en
s'internationalisant en S
internationalisant en en termees de
développement mais aussi en terme de
capital ce sont désintéressés du
territoire et ont d'une certaine manière
pas que d'une certaine manière une
responsabilité dans la
désindustrialisation quand un donneur
d'ordre décide d'aller implanter un site
d'assemblage par exemple de véhicules à
l'étranger avec les règles de juste àant
qui sont propres à l'automobile en
général c'est toute la chaîne de
sous-traitance qui se qui se qui se
délocalise et et ça c'est c'est quand
même quelque chose qui est assez propre
à la France l'Italie N a moins de grand
groupe que nous a beaucoup de PME qui
sont très solidaires entre entre elles
très ancré dans un dans un territoire et
donc ça explique aussi peut-être que la
France
soit autant des parties de de de de sa
de sa culture industrielle et il y a
peut-être un bémol que je
mettrai parce que c'est les exemple
récent si on est on était resté dans le
dans dans dans la logique actuelle et
que Total était resté un groupe détenu
par l'État je suis pas convaincu que
Total ferait 20 milliards d'euros de
Bénéfic aujourd'hui pour la simple et
bonne raison pour des question gestion
des questions de culture industrielle
des questions de doctrine d'État on
regarde l'état par exemple a quand même
encore pas mal de participation dans un
certain nombre d'entreprises notamment
dans Renault quand on voit la manière
dont est géré la conversion du véhicule
thermique vers le véhicule électrique et
le nombre d'entreprises en difficulté
notamment des fonderies qui sont obligés
de fermer qu'elles sont en situation de
dépendance de Renault on se demande
pourquoi l'État qui est un actionnaire
de Renault ne joue pas beaucoup plus le
jeu de transition plus lo mais parce que
je pense que aujourd'hui l'agence des
participation de l'État ne considère pas
que ça soit son
rôle de donner une direction d'avoir une
une vision sur le rôle de l'État en tant
que participation vas-y anal termine non
non mais c'est bon je je d'accord donc
là là
j'entends général de gaoule Pompidou moi
je vais vous dire Bernard et zambert
programme thermonucléaire Françis bien
sûr que c'est Pompidou mais nous on a eu
de la chance de pouvoir se s'éiguiser
les canines sur son vieux sur ses vieux
mollets d'une façon sans filtre et ça
forme un jeune
homme le Commissariat au Plan c'est une
vaste blague c'est un truc sans
moisépinière c'est qu'est-ce que c'est
c'est quelque chose de positif c'est
quelque chose qui a su imprimer sa patte
pour tresser et tracer une
trajectoire robuste c'est robuste qui
vous fait rire c'estot c'est une charade
ouis je je me pose la question une
question bête où est la l'pinière où est
le système nerveux français où est le
regard où est le regard au
laser je pense que le Commissariat au
Plan le le Haut Commissariat au Plan
aujourd'hui c'est une agence sans
administration bon de retraite en épad
oui en grande partie puisquen fait comme
ils sont ils sont ils sont tout à fait
impuissants vous allez mettre là les
personnes que vous voulez mettre au
placard mais ce qui est intéressant
c'est de les comparer au premier
Commissariat au Plan celui de de 46 le
premier Commissariat au Plan il y avait
une véritable volonté politique derrière
d'investir dans six secteurs
stratégiques donc déjà il y avait pas de
dispersion mais surtout oui don dont
l'électricité pardon dont l'énergie don
l'armement l'armement la métallurgie et
cetera au lendemain de la guerre on est
dans le contexte de la reconstruction
mais surtout ils avaient une
administration ça veut dire que il y
avait le Commissariat au Plan qui
pilotait la stratégie mais derrière vous
avez les grands corps d'état notamment
les corps des Ponts et Chaussées les
corps d'ingénieurs vous aviez des
techniciens et des ingénieurs d'état
vous aviez le ministère de l'Équipement
le ministère de l'Équipement c'était
120000 ingénieurs et techniciens qui
connais qui connaissaient tout le
territoire c'est à eux que l'on doit nos
routes nos ponts le tunnel sous la
Manche une partie de l'architecture de
nos centrales nucléaires nos barrages
nos barrages hydroélectriques et
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait et ça je retrace
en détail dans mon livre on pour revenir
dessus ça vous intéresse mais on s'en
fout de ton l on a on a supprimé le
ministère de l'Équipement on s'est dit
on en a plus besoin on a plus besoin du
ministère de l'Équipement on a viré tous
ces ingénieurs aujourd'hui on a plus
personne dans l'état qui sait faire ce
genre de chos et on a juste gardé le
sommet donc aujourd'hui le somm il peut
bien écrire ce qu'il veut il écrit des
rapports et cetera moi j'étais en train
de débattre avec le secrétariat
président du secrétariat général à la
transition
écologique planification écologique
pardon et puis il me dit il faut faire
ça en 2035 il faut que l'on devienne les
leaders mondiaux des énergies
renouvelables il faut qu'on exploite les
fondmarins et cetera je disais mais qui
va faire ça c'est ni toi ni moi qui va
le
faire oui et comme on en parallèle on
est en train de continuer à fermer nos
formations d'ingénieur on en a plus au
sein de l'État on se fout de la gueule
des écoles d'apprentissage on se fout de
la gueule des écoles d'apprentissage l
oui c'est qui un scandale de soudeur
pour nos centrales nucléaires exactement
on a plus de soudeur pour les centrales
nucléaires jusqu'à la maîtrise d'ouvrage
qui s'est perdu et puis bon tout le
monde partle dans la finance et le
conseil donc on a beaucoup de financiers
beaucoup de consultants donc beaucoup de
gens qui nous disent qu'il faudrait
faire mais derrière plus personne pour
faire donc on a beaucoup de gens qui
nous disent il a qu' fau con je parle je
chat je je dialectique je prends le
contrôle de la dialectique j'influence
ton politique sauf que derrière la
politique industrielle c'est je sculpte
de l'air chaud je brasse de la fumée
c'est quoi ça j'ai j'ai c'est quoi le
nom de ton bouquin déjà tu as dit qu'on
s'en fout la destruction de l'État la
destruction de l'État marouned édition
bouquin franchement ça vaut le coup
Anaïs c'est quoi ton bouquin toi
d'ailleurs euh mon bouquin c'est pour
une révolution industrielle éditionition
les press de la cité ah non pardon qui
sort dans 2 jours
on va le montrer on va le montrer avec
la couverture vaut le coup c'est vrai a
un peu de Bernie Sanders dedans non
ouais on c'est beaucoup amusé pour
revenir pour revenir à la moelle
épinière à la politique industrielle non
non non non la moelle épinière la
détection de menaces nous on aime bien
faire de la prospective on on module
tout on on essaie de modéliser en terme
de stratégie guerrière en terme de
guerre économique en terme de de
robustesse en terme de protection
on a une vision très
agressive qui est censé dans l'état
avoir cette vision agressive défensive
conquérente sans pitié qui est censé
veiller à la santé de nos industries
veiller à l'incompressible de
consommation énergétique recyclage des
déchets consommation d'eau et j'en
passer des meilleurs qui il faut qu'on
aille chercher par la peau des fesses
pour leur dire maintenant on va vous
poser des questions et tant que vous
avez pas fini on va s'acharner vos
résultats sont médiocres la France estun
dans une trajectoire dangereuse je veux
et j'exige des responsables
qui je je je pense un bon un bon
interlocuteur serait la Direction
Générale des Entreprises et je crois
qu'il y a au sein de la Direction
générale des entreprises des gens qui
sont convaincus de ça mais la question
est l'administration elle répond aussi à
une vision à un projet de société or
aujourd'hui à partir du moment où il y a
pas forcément un pilote qui imprègne
cette vision ou collectivement on
partage pas des grandes directions elle
elle elle ne elle ne peut pas agir seule
c'estàdire on va si je peux ouais merci
là on parle même plus de partager une
vision l'action sort du rêve là on est
en train de parler de je fais le constat
de qui va commencer à me manger c'est
les vers les piragnas les vautours les
ours les loups va nous bouffer une en
fait une action de Guera ou de de de de
des gueras économique tu ne peux pas l'
menener seul ça peut pas être uniquement
une administration l'administration dit
demain il y a un tel qui veut racheter
telle entreprise on veut pas on bloque
on active tel décret pour dire on ne on
on ne vend pas parce que c'est un actif
stratégique pour la
France très bien mais derrière il faut
qu'il y ait des gens qui soient prêts
soit à racheter ces entreprises
c'est-à-dire est-ce qu'on a des fond
d'investissement français qui sont prêts
à prendre les participations dans cette
entreprise est-ce qu'on a des
entreprises industrielles qui sont prê
prête à la racheter ou est-ce qu'on est
capable de la nationaliser parce que
c'est vraiment ça représente vraiment un
intérêt stratégique c'est-à-dire que une
administration elle peut mettre une
alerte je pense que si on prend
l'exemple de de de tout ce qui se passe
dans le domaine militaire et de la
défense où on a une base industriel
c'est c'est c'est certainement
criticable mais c'est aujourd'hui ce
qu'on a peut-être de plus alerte en
terme de guerre économique en France que
ce qu'on a dans le reste l'écomie non
mais non mais non la la l'île Longue qui
se fait gauler avec Strava non mais oh
on avait déjà goulé la DGSE le numéro 2
de la DGSE on était remonté jusqu'en bas
de chez lui l'intelligence économique
elle est où là si déjà que tu te fais
Gaer sur ta de propre base non
mais tu considères que de toute manière
c'est un problème systémique et que
c'est pas le le le le le sujet et que
soit on a des on a des gens qui je
penseont qui ont un travail de de de
lanceur d'alerte et en fait l'enjeu de
la guerre économique aujourd'hui c'est
de la sortirre des marges quel est quel
est le parce que la la guerre économique
en France ça reste quelque chose qui est
porté par des gens qu'on
classifie plutôt au marge et qui ne sont
pas forcément écout je dire parler de
guerre économique ça devient peut-être
mainstream depuis la guerre en Ukraine
mais pendant très longtemps les gens qui
parlaient de de guerre économique des
gens comme arbulo Nicolas moanet
Philippe caduc on on en passe c'est ce
sont des gens qu'on a pendant longtemps
mis au marge de de la réflexion voire
qu'on pass cétait des pointes de diamant
des des des doudingues ou des non non je
veux dire pour certains c'est des
doudingues qui qui crient
que tout va mal des cassendre tout ce
que tu veux mais que finalement les
choses va passer mal et maintenant
maintenant on prend conscience de la
situation dans laquelle on est ou
c'était considéré comme pour certains
des nationalistes enfin je dire il y a
pas dans dans la
réflexion générale portée et qui irait
avec une politique industrielle cette
notion de comment on se protège des
attaques des autres des ingérences et
cetera parce que parce que le le le
système n'est pas programmé la doctrine
qu'on défend n'est pas programmé pour
intégrer ces questions au cœur sinon ta
politique industrielle elle serait
différente Robert guillaumo Bernard et
zbert feu Bernard feu Robert
guillaumo inventeur du concept
d'intelligence économique et de guerre
économique
bernardambert qui n'est qui est toujours
parmi nous mais j'en parler avec eux il
y a 20 ans et c'est c'est sûr ça
représenta un pouillem il y a cette
doctrine de défense et la question c'est
pourquoi ces gens-là qui deviennent
lanceurs d'alerte restent dans les
administrations pourquoi ils
démissionnent pas tous parce que il faut
payer le crédit payer le crédit de la
voiture payer le crédit de la maison il
y a il faut il faut rentrer avec un
salaire parce que sinon on est
déclassé pourquoi on a plus des têtes
brûlé des vrais entrepreneurs un pays de
vieux tu es un pays de vieux à partir du
moment où tu où tu vie enfin les gens
enfin je ve dire on est un pays de vieux
on est une économie de vieux on on on on
on galère innover et euh tuas tu as le
le sentiment aussi d'avoir un phénomène
de stagnation sociale et donc tout le
monde est aujourd'hui tétanisé l'Europe
c'est c'est un un continent où on a peur
on a peur de tout on a peur du risque
c'est pour ça qu'on investit pas on a
peur on a peur d'innover on se prémunit
de tous les risques qui existent plutôt
que de dire on essaye et on régulera
après on régule avant même que le risque
le risque n'apparaisse et à certains
égards c'est bien de réguler certains
risques mais il y a un équilibre à à à
trouver
eTTH j'ai un un copain qui me disait il
y a 3 jours finalement l'Europe son son
grand problème son grand péché c'est les
étoiles mortes
parce que on ne brille on ne voit que
que des choses du passé de de quoi on
parle en France c'est qui notre modèle
en France de qui on parle depuis je sais
pas combien commencé quelle est la
figure
50 minutes et 53 secondes qui c'est la
seule image tutellaaire en disant
c'était bien c'est le général de Gaulle
et c'est Pompidou et je te renvoie à la
première fois tu m'as invité
i c'était non mais c'était pour une
punch line où je disais enfin je dire
quand on a peut-être pas quand on a 25
ans en tout cas quand on en a 33 je veux
dire moi j'en ai marre que la seule F
figure qui reste en France ça soit le
général de Gaulle alors ok un Elon Musk
moi il me fait pas rêver pour plein de
raisons mais je pense qu'il fait rêver
des générations on n pas une figure
politique on n pas une figure
entrepreneuriale on n pas une figure
culturelle alors peut-être un culturelle
qui fait rêver les jeunes générations
qui nous donne envie de transcender de
rêver de construire autre chose parce
que c'est la question qui se pose à
l'Europe aujourd'hui c'est bon sent
bonsoir comment on se réveille et on
construit un projet de société qui nous
mobilise et qui soit pas défensif contre
les autres il faut qu'on est la on
dire on a un truc à reconstruire les
Chinois vous voulez mettre vendre des
trucs en France et ben soit vous adoptez
nos normes soit vous restez chez vous
vous voulez implanter une usine et ben
vous faites un transfert de technologie
comme on l'a fait les Américains on vous
les vendre chez nous et ben vous
localisez votre production comme tout le
monde le fait et on va me dire je suis
une horrible protectionniste c'est juste
de la réciprocité finalement du bon sens
de la réciprocité tout ce qu'on veut
c'est ce moi j'ai vraiment envie de me
donner les moyens de choisir dans le
futur l'économie que je veux je veux
construire avec les autres personnes de
ma génération j'ai pas envie qu'il me
reste plus rien
finalement crevé comme une saucisse
cocktail à cause du réchauffement
climatique les menaces qui se
DESS son les
menaces pour la France pour l'Europe à
court et moyen terme cette année plan de
licenciement plan plans sociau
d'évaluation de la dette dévaluation de
la note de la dette
française qu'estce qui ement ça va faire
quoi dans dans les foyers français on
vit à crédit on parle que on dit qu'il
faut réduire le déficit mais on parle
que du volet des dépenses publiques on
parle trop peu du volet des recettes
publiques le le vrai problème dont on
parle depuis tout à l'heure c'est qu'on
a diminué les recettes parce que avant
on arrivait à produire vous aviez des
entreprises qui payaient des impôts qui
avaient des gens qui travaillaient pour
eux qui payaient des impôts également
vous aviez des entreprises l'état
possédait aussi des entreprises l'État
était riche rien que les autoroutes par
exemple qu'on a qu'on a privatisé en
tout cas pour une concession pour 35 ans
le manque à gagn c'est 10 milliards
d'euros par an cash que vous payez avec
vos péages donc aujourd'hui vous avez
Dominique de vilpin qui a privatiser ça
Dominique de villepa en 2006 et puis
Emmanuel Macron en 2015 avec un
protocole tenu secret pendant 4 ans qui
a autorisé notamment les acteurs privés
qui les avaent à augmenter le prix des
péages plus rapidement que l'inflation
donc ça déjà vous allez tout payer plus
cher parce qu'il y a plus aucune notion
de service public en tout cas à partir
du moment où s'est privatisé je disais
on vit à crédit c'est parce que on a un
modèle social qui est ambitieux on veut
l'école gratuite on veut les hôpitaux
gratuits on veut pouvoir être protégé
contre les risques de la vie notamment
avec l'assurance chômage avec les
retraites et je pense qu'il faut le
défendre il faut le défendre il faut pas
utiliser la solution de Ronald Ragan qui
dit la sécurité sociale ça coûte cher je
vais la supprimer d'accord mais derrière
vous avez des besoins si vous la
supprimez il va bien falloir gérer le
problème d'une autre façon le problème
c'est que pour le défendre il faut quand
même avoir un système qui permette qui
permette de le financer en train de me
dire que la Sécurité Sociale française
va canner là bah en fait aujourd'hui on
s'entête pour la payer donc à partir du
moment où les pays refusent de vous
prêter ou disons vous prête à des taux
de plus en plus importants et donc vous
allez utiliser une part majeure de ce
que vous vous endettez rien que pour
payer les intérêts annuels de la dette
effectivement vous n'allez plus pouvoir
payer la sécurité sociale c'est en train
de venir peu à peu on réduit les
remboursements des
médicaments on régule aussi par l'offre
par les déserts
médicaux les jours de carence vous
voulez trouver un médecin vous voulez
trouver un che chirurgien vous devez
attendre 6 mois bon courage et donc en
fait c'est en train de se réduire vous
voulez les écoles publiques il y a des
endroits dans lesquels l'école publique
devientent désastreuse vous êtes obligé
d'aller dans l'école privée votre enfant
sur parcours sup il ne trouve plus de
place à l'université donc vous avez des
acteurs privés qui s'en mettent plein
les poches en lui vendant souvent des
faux diplômes et cetera c'est en train
de venir peu à peu on voit la délicac
des faux diplômes diplômes pas reconnus
des diplômes non reconnus non reconnus
par l'État exactement master eu accent
grave vers eux plutôt que master bref et
donc à partir de là on on on on le voit
venir euh peu à peu ce qui risque de se
passer c'est un choc moi la princip la
première principale crainte c'est un
choc c'est-à-dire aujourd'hui on finance
par l'endettement notre modèle social
demain la dette devient trop cher ou on
refuse de nous endetter qu'est-ce qui va
se passer et bah c'est le modèle social
en premier qui va trinquer on l'a vu
violemment en Grèce euh aujourd'hui les
urgences publiques en Grèce ça fait peur
alors on meurt aussi dans les urgences
publiques de plus en plus en France et
c'est et c'est terrible euh mais et
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui les services
publics en Grèce il reste plus
grandchose donc retour du score but en
France magnifique ouais c'est une belle
press magnifque c'est c'est c'est plus
la startup nation c'est la scorebut
nation il reste encore beaucoup en
France heureusement les gens sont encore
là mais le problème quand vous
sous-financez et ça peut même être
instrumentalisé c'est c'est la stratégie
star the beast c'està dire affamer la
bête qui a été développé notamment par
les conseillers de Ronald Reagan qui
consiste à dire bon les services publics
c'est embêtant ça génère pas de profit
il faut privatiser tout ça si vous
décidez demain de privatiser l'hôpital
de remplacer que par des cliniques
privées de privatiser les autoroutes et
cetera les gens vont gueuler parce
qu'ils doivent tout payer plus cher et
ils doivent même payer double parce
qu'ils continuent à payer autant
d'impôts mais derrière ils ont plus la
contrepartie ils doivent en plus payer
l'école pour leurs enfants et cetera
qu'est-ce que vous faites vous réduisez
progressivement les moyens et
j'interroge notamment une infirmière qui
me racontait elle me disait moi quand
j'ai commencé on était à 10 pour 100
patients la nuit dans mon service
d'urgence comme d'autres urgences sont
fermé comme on a supprimé des postes
maintenant on est à 5 pour 200 forcément
on fait moins bien le travail forcément
il y a des erreurs forcément il y a des
bavures l'infirmière engueule l'interne
et cetera et et donc comme ça fonctionne
moins bien maltraitance sur les patients
il y a de la maltraitance sur les
patients ça fonctionne moins bien donc
on va vous dire bah vous voyez quand
c'est géré par l'État ça ne marche pas
il va maintenant falloir privatiser et
pour revenir sur l'idée de se dire oui
mais les entreprises géré par l'État ne
fonctionne pas oui et non déjà
effectivement l'Agence des participation
de l'État n'a plus de stratégie
industrielle tout court mais c'est
intéressant de voir qu'en Chine ils ont
fait l'inverse de nous ils ont privatisé
surtout les entreprises qui marchaient
moyennement et ils ont gardé public les
fleurons et donc maintenant ils disent
ah bah regardez les entreprises
publiques ça marche bien qu'est-ce qu'on
a fait en France tout ce qui pouvait
rapporter du profit on l'a privatisé on
a collectivisé les pertes tout ce qui
marchait moyennement ou tout ce qui
nécessitait beaucoup de coup on la
gardait publi et maintenant on dit ah
bah regardez les entreprises publiques
ça perd de l'argent ça dépend juste
comment vous construisez votre
portefeuille d'entreprise publique après
la différence entre la la France et la
Chine ou entre l'Union européne et la
Chine Chine c'est que la Chine a aussi
une vraie stratégie industrielle et
alors c'est une dictature ce qui permet
de décider de fermer une usine quand
elle ne respecte pas les règles qu'on se
fixe et cetera mais la Chine a une
stratégie industrielle a une stratégie
pour assurer son autonomie et donc dans
cette stratégie la politique
industrielle avec le plan main in China
2025 la volonté de devenir indépendant
dans des secteurs qu'elle juge clés
comme les semi-onducteur mais a aussi la
stratégie des nouvelles routes de la
soie qui est une stratégie à la fois de
maîtrise de la prov ionement des
matières premières critiques et c'est
pour ça que la Chine aujourd'hui leader
en terme d'extraction et de raffinage
d'une majorité de matières premières
critiques en particulier celle
nécessaire à la transition écologique
mais c'est aussi créer des voies pour
exporter ces produits dans le reste du
monde c'est aussi une façon de bypasser
la sécurisation du colier de perles par
les États-Unis c'est-à-dire les routes
d'exportation de la Chine constellé de
base américaine ils se sont dit ou là là
si du jour au lendemain ils ont décidé
de nous embêter com ont fait donc ils
ont fait un plan B en France qui fait
les plans B qui fait les plans B qui
fait les plans a ouais qui fait parce
que je un autre risque on parlait des
principaux risques mais par exemple moi
liya ça m'inquiète beaucoup parce que
est-ce que l'incompétence est dangereuse
bah elle est tout à fait justement je
reprends cet exemple ça va nous nous
arriver en pleine figure avec des
conséquences sociales qui peuvent être
désastreuses sur les sur les emplois sur
les données personnelles les
conséquences psychologiques les
conséquences éducatives euh par exemple
une question toute simple hein sans
parler de Guer économique et tout
comment demain on adapte l'école alors
que l' a existe et que on sait que tout
le monde a accès à chat GPT bon ben moi
j'avais essayé oui pardon non c'est moi
j'avais j'avais essayé de porter
justement un plan pour apprendre
l'informatique aux élèves à l'école et
donc on va voir le codage apprendre quoi
oui exactement en fait c'était un plan à
la base pour essayer de transformer la
technologie qui elle-même est restée
bloquée dans les années 70 en
apprentissage notamment du e mais aussi
de disons de de la base d'outils qui
permet de naviguer aujourd'hui dans un
monde très fortement digitalisé et pour
en devenir aussi des producteurs et pas
seulement des consommateurs c'était
l'ambition on va voir le cabinet
ministériel al le directeur cabinet n'y
connaissait rien d'ailleurs World il
connaissait pas trop hein c'était sa
secrétaire qui ce que ça voulait dire c
de points je sais pas je sais pas il
nous a dit alleer voir euh c'était la la
dne ou la enfin c'était la direction du
numérique et du
eux ils savent on va les voir c'était un
ensemble de vieux qui était juste là
pour financer ce qu'on appelait des
ztech c'est quoi des vieux c'était des
gens qui avaient fait leur carrière qui
avaient qui avait 60 ans et qui
finançaient des ztech c'est-à-dire des
start-ups époque de la startup nation
qui promettait avec le numérique de tout
révolutionner j'ai dû en voir quatre qui
étaient correct sur 100 et ça de
l'argent public à fois an on nous dit ah
non mais ça c'est pas nous il faut que
vous alliez voir le ministère du
numérique alors on va voir le ministère
du numérique je parle à la directrice de
cabinet
c'est elle avait fait elle avait fait
Science Po donc elle me disait non mais
je va parl code et tout elle m'a dit
vous avez une vision trop technique du
numérique le numérique c'est avant tout
un changement de société par rapport à
la transition écologique au Smart cities
et tout le secrétaire d'État de l'époque
c'était qui c'était je crois que CIT
Cédric c'est àir et bajoubi il y avait
moyen de discuter qu ouais c'est ça mais
et Axel le mer encore plus probablement
j'ai pas eu de chance et on finit par
aller voir la région î de France et là
la région nous dit ah mais c'est dommage
parce que on a on a eu des budgets pour
équiper en numérique voilà on a payé en
tout à l'échelle nationale 2,5 milliards
pour équiper les établissements en
numérique simplement voilà comme on
savait pas on a choisi des tablettes et
pas des ordis or on peut pas coder sur
des tablettes bon bah dommage on a et ça
a été revendu sur le bon coin et et
probablement ou bien j'ai vu des
collèges où ça a juste été enfermé dans
des cadis qui servent pas parce que ils
ont peur de les casser et comme on n pas
mis en place le budget de maintenance et
ben juste voilà c'est un coup et puis
probablement aujourd'hui cétait y a prob
aujourd'hui elle fonctionne plus donc
donc voilà c'est c'est un petit exemple
mais qui vous montre par rapport au choc
qui arrivve qu'on n pas prêt question
pour vous
deux est-ce que notre système éducatif
doit être vu et construit comme une
industrie une usine pour les futurs
besoins et les futurs
talents que la France devrait utiliser
où est-ce queon doit avoir un système
éducatif pour forger l'âme forger la
personn
la
créativité la question est
biaisée elle est un peu vache enfin elle
est un peu je pense qu'il faut est-ce
que une licence d'histoire ou une
histoire de l'art c'est intéressant en
ce moment il faut arm la sociologie du
machin du bidule on peut pas savoir
quelles
sontme on peut pas savoir quelles sont
les compétences don a besoin dans 10 ans
le plus important c'est d'apend d'armer
l'esprit d'apprendre à apprendre et ça
vous le faites disons jusqu'à la
terminale en gros voire jusqu'à la
licence mais ça il faut donner une base
ça va être de plus en plus difficile de
s'orienter dans le monde avec en plus
tout ce qu'on ce qu'on lit tout ce qu'on
voit c'est cet excès d'information il
faut former l'esprit il faut l'armé
notamment et je pense que l'histoire la
géographie tout ce qui peut instiller du
patriotisme le fait de d'être fier aussi
de son pays ça c'est extrêmement
important là où probablement il faut
spécialiser beaucoup plus c'est à la fin
c'estàd qu'aujourd'hui l'enseignement
supérieur français l'enseignement
français est bien parce qu'il est
généraliste mais il reste généraliste à
la fin et vous avez aujourd'hui à
l'université 300000 personnes en lettres
langues et art 30000 personnes en
mathématiques 25000 en physique bon le
niveau de mat des Français vient de se
vterer de combien de place l'anné on n
pas les derniers de CDE avant dernier
avantdernier on est les avant-dernier de
l'OCDE mais disons que le classement
PISA quand vous regardez en détail les
premiers les top 10 % sont au niveau de
de de de Singapour exactement et les
derniers 10 % sont entre le Pérou et
l'Azerbaïjan qui sont moins connus pour
leur excellent niveau en mats donc il y
a ça aussi c'estàd qu'on sacrifie les 90
% et on garde une petite élite qui
permet de masquer ce sacrifice mais pour
pour revenir suréducation je pense qu'il
faut spécialiser à la fin c'est-à-dire
que
aujourd'hui on a beaucoup trop de places
qui sont ouvertes effectivement dans des
endroits qui ne conduisent nulle part et
le pire c'est qu'on responsabilise
l'échec on le fait porter aux gens
c'est-à-dire que l'étudiant bah il
choisit ça parce que on lui a dit fais
ce que tu aimes et cetera et c'est là où
la réforme du bac aussi a été terrible
parce qu'on on donne l'illusion aux gens
qui peuvent choisir ce qu'ils veulent
derrière ils ont pas de métier leurs
parents leur disent oui mais moi avec un
brevet et un bac j'ai eu un meilleur job
que toi pourquoi tu arrives pas à avoir
un job toi tu es en bac plus 3 tu es nul
eux disent parent c'est vous qui m'avez
poussé là c'est un scandale et tout et
donc on responsabilise l'échec alors que
c'est orchestré par l'institution
elle-même et par la lâcheté absolue du
fait qu'on ose pas réformer ça adéice eu
alors donc assurément quand on parle
d'industrie je pense qu'on a besoin
d'avoir des niveaux de formation en math
et en physique qui doivent être beaucoup
plus élevés et que en effet on a on a
quelques gens qui font a renommé des
mathématiques françaises grâce à des
mdailles fields et en même temps on voit
bien que le niveau baisse et ne nous
permettra pas peut-être de garder et de
réaugmenter le rythme d'innovation de
recherche et cetera maintenan j'pposerai
pas d'un côté besoin de former pour les
besoins d'un pays et des formations qui
ne serviraient à rien je crois qu'on a
on a besoin de gens qui sont capables de
ne pas raisonner en silo et pour être
capable de ne pas raisonner en silo ça
demande aussi d'avoir une une culture
une formation en sciences humaines ce
qu'on appelait il y a très longtemps
faire ses humanités d'une certaine
manière même si c'est le grec qui est de
l'tin et que peut-être que c'est pas ce
dont on a on a on a besoin euh
aujourd'hui en tout cas on a quand même
besoin d'avoir un un un un Tron commun
culturel qui nous donne des armes pour
penser le monde dans sa complexité et
avoir une vision systémique de de ce qui
se passe vous pouvez être le meilleur
ingénieur dans un domaine si vous êtes
pas capable de comprendre les
problématiques des des autres comprendre
les effet de bord quand vous fonctionnez
dans votre silo alors ça produira
quelque chose de génial mais sur un seul
point alors que pour changer une société
on a besoin d'avoir des gens qui sont
capables de d'appréhender ça de manière
de manière systémique et donc on a
besoin d'experts pointus dans certains
domaines mais avec une connaissance
assez aussi enfin garder un savoir assez
ass large he c'est le parcours
généraliste dont parle Maroun et en même
temps on a besoin d'avoir des gens qui
sont capables d'avoir cette vision
systémique ce qu'on offre plus plus dans
un certain nombre d'écooles
c'est-à-dire on on on est on est un peu
c'est pas parce qu'on fait une formation
en histoire qu'on est capable d' une
vision systémique on peut rester dans
dans son couloir de nage de la même
manière qu'on peut l'a en mathématique
ou en philo en philosophie et et
historien des États-Unis 3 semaines
avant les les élections affirm bec et
ongle défendre bec et ongle que camela
Harris elle va passer que c'est la
meilleure candidate contre Trump et on
peut toujours être sur le service public
et avoir une production capillaire
extraordinaire et ne jamais être remis
en question mais c'est pas grave chose
une chose à dire en complément de de de
ça c'est euh pour revenir un peu a ce
qui ce qui avait été dit le le fait que
bah les parents avec une formation moins
importante avaient peut-être le
sentiment de mieux vivre que leur que
leur que leurs parents à eux et que là
on est fa face à un phénomène de de
stagnation sociale et ça c'est aussi lié
au fait que en fait on généralise
l'accès à un diplôme bac + 5 quand on
arrive avec un diplôme bac + 5 et ben on
s'attend à avoir une place par exemple
un salaire une place de management dans
dans dans dans d'un niveau management
dans une entreprise et cetera et en fait
on peut pas produire autant euh de de de
de de de place auquell on peut espérer
avec tel diplôme que ce que ce que le ce
queon fournit en terme de de diplômé et
donc on est en train de créer une
machine à à à frustration parce qu'on a
ce phénomène de stagnation et qu'on sait
qu'aujourd'hui on vivra il y a un risque
que notre génération viv moins bien que
celle de de de ses de ses parents c'est
c'est déjà oui déjà le cas et ça sera
sûrement le cas encore plus dans dans
retraite des baby boomers euh il y a
combien de cootisant pour combien de
retrait déjà là bon juste une question
qu'est-ce qui se passe quand il y a une
un effet de frustration sociale de
stagnation sociale et des des
indicateurs précurseurs sur l'énergie
l'économie le business ces indicateurs
avancés qui nous indiquent clairement
qu'on est le mur se rapproche à grande
vitesse socialement parlant ça donne
quoi une petite boucherie des
guillotines dans les jardins ça ça donne
les gilets jaunes sous stéroïdes ça fait
euh cet électrochop qui permettra aux
Français de reprendre leur destin en
main ça dépend comment vous interpréter
le problème en fait est-ce que faire du
France bashing c'est maintenant
nécessaire pour qu'on voit les choses en
face c'est-àdire vous avez jamais marqué
on a tous fait des conférences ici on a
tous on s'est tous balader dans les
conférences et dès qu'il y en a un qui
commence à dire bon il va falloir quand
même qu'on se secoue les pces les puces
tout de suite c'est oh là là monsieur
fait du fra Bing monsieur monsieur
monsieur est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression que toutes notre élite nos
grands corps nos grandes lunettes nos
grandes moustaches nos grandes oreilles
c'est
branquignol c'est si on fait du French
bashing c'est remettre les remettre avec
leur nez un petit peu dans leur caca
est-ce que branquignol sera le mot de
2025 non je pense que ce sera un autre
d'accord des coup il faut rester
jusqu'au bout pour savoir le un des
problèmes c'est que les constats sont
partagés mais les analyses sont très
diverses il suffit d'allumer la télé on
va vous parler par
exemple on va vous répéter
euh la pente dangereuse par exemple des
sujets identitaire et donc en fait euh
les gens voient le même constat sauf que
on vous donne pas les mêmes clés
d'explication on dit c'est la faute d'un
tel c'est la faute de tel groupe c'est
la faute d'entelle c'est lui qui a fait
ça c'est parce qu'il y a trop d'État il
nous faut encore moins d'État c'est
parce que
euh les gens les jeunes sont trop
paresseux ah regardez tous ces jeunes
ils veulent plus travailler ils sont
trop assistés tout le monde est assisté
notre modèle social est trop lourd il
faut le détruire et cetera donc les gens
voient la même chose mais comme vous
leur mettez sans cesse dans la tête
l'idée que le mal est le remède ils vont
continuer à s'y engouffrer et vous avez
plein d'exemples où en fait c'est juste
qu'il y avait pas assez d'état ou plus
assez d'État au bon endroit mais comme
on s'est dit ah ça dysfonctionne c'est
forcément parce qu'il y a trop d'état
parce que c'est ce qu'on nous répète
tout le temps et donc on continue à
couper et on continue à aggraver le
problème qu'on a créé donc la réaction
des gens dépendra beaucoup et et et je
pense que c'est pour ça qu'on est là et
c'est pour ça qu'on essaie de de de
d'expliquer ça c'est que ça dépendra
beaucoup des clés d'explication qu'on
les donne les constats ils vont être
partagés les gens vont bien voir que ils
vont perdre du pouvoir d'achat que
désormais l'école elle va être payante
que ils vont plus pouvoir envoyer leurs
enfants à l'université alors qu'ils
rêvaient de ça depuis le début qu'X
urgences publiques ils attendre
maintenant 24h 12h je sais pas ça il le
voit mais comment est-ce qu'il
l'interprète est-ce que le problème des
urgences publiques c'est parce que il y
a trop de Mamadou est-ce que c'est parce
que il y a je crois qu'on a un président
de la République qui a dit
ça est-ce que c'est parce que il y a une
administration intermédiaire qui est
devenue plétorique qui représente 34 à
40 % des effectifs de l'hôpital est-ce
que c'est parce qu'il y a des
intermédiaires comme des cabinets de
conseil qui s'en mettent plein les
poches en mettant du reporting dans tous
les sens et en empêchant les médecins et
les infirmiers de faire correctement
leur travail parce qu'il les noix sous
de la bureaucratie et et des rapports à
faire c'est ça dépend comment votre
réaction dépend de comment vous
l'interprétez et le problème c'est que
on n pas en France je pense les bonnes
grilles d'interprétation notamment en
partie parce que on vit aussi dans dans
le passé dans nos nos grilles de
réflexion on est là avec des catégories
qui sont franchement aujourd'hui
complètement
dépassées et et et donc en fait si on
narrive pas à bien interpréter on va mal
réagir il risque d'y avoir un choc mais
pas pas dans le bon sens et pas
forcément contre les vrais responsables
est-ce que vous an vous avez un sujet
qui vous tient à cœur sur l'industrie ou
sur le tissu français ou sur les élites
françaises ou sur l'industrie
française un truc qui me à C truc qui
qui vous pèse quand vous allumez la télé
qu'est-ce qui vous pèse le plus non mais
alors ce qui me pèse le plus c'est que
les gens qui parlent l'industrie sont
rarement des gens qui vont vraiment voir
ce qui est une usine la réalité de ce
qui est l'industrie il y a plein de
choses qu'on pourrait dire il y a un
truc par exemple qui qui qui m'énerve on
dit en permanence l'industrie c'est plus
ola et j'ai envie de dire heureusement
que c'est plus ola c'était il y a 200
ans par contre en disant ça on révèle
aussi qu'on méconnaî la réalité du
travail d'un certain nombre de gens qui
qui sont dans l'industrie il y a de la
pénibilité dans l'industrie il y a des
conditions de travail difficiles et on
va pas moins tirer dans l'industrie en
disant qu'il y a des choses difficiles
il y a des métiers pénibles dans les
activités de service aussi donc il faut
décrire l'industrie pour ce qu'elle est
comment elle doit encore se transformer
comment elle doit accompagner les
transformations de notre société et
surtout expliquer en quoi l'industrie
est vraiment vitale pour notre notre
notre éconie un autre mot que
transformation euh progrès survivre
survivre survivre sur oui alors ça c'est
vraiment on est vraiment négatif
pas rose on n pas de lunette rose quand
vous voyez du Alex non mais là c'est
bien sûr que c'est la survie quand vous
voyez c'est quoi l'espèce de d'industrie
de métallurgie qui est en train de se
transformer en musée là quand vous voyez
tout ça il faut
oui mais alors quand on voit pour se
transformer il faut toujours être vivant
he quand quand on voit on voit on voit
tout ça on se dit plusieurs choses la
première c'est bon on adore le French
bashing on adore dire que tout va mal en
France he c'est c'est un mal et et il
faut peut-être montrer le positif mais
du coup on a envie de dire arrêtons de
faire des rapports faisons des actions
distri distribuons des grandes gifles de
bûcheron ouais alors moi j'ai pas la
capacité de mettre des gifles du
bûcheron parce que je suis un peu de
consistance fragile donc je sais pas si
je pourrais le faire mais en tout cas
c'est de se dire bon qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est-ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui pourquoi
l'industrie va mal problème
énergétique l'énergie est trop chère
elle est structurellement trop cher en
Europe par rapport plus cher en Europe
par rapport je peux me faire l'avocat du
diable allez allons-y non mais mais
l'énergie est trop cher mais comment ça
se fait qu'elle est trop cher bah parce
que on a pas vu parce qu'on a pas
anticipé parce qu'on sait pas ce que
c'est un pic pétrolier on sait pas ce
que c'est un pic des ressources parce
que on vient de se faire botter le cul
d'Afrique on vient de se faire botter le
cul à gauche que la seule mine
potentiellement productiviste d'uranium
au Kazakhstan bah en fin de compte elle
délivre un peu moins l'anticipation de
ou aujourd'hui on a pas anticipé donc on
est on est dans on est dans dans la
merde donc maintenant on va se dire
quelles sont les actions que je peux
mettre à court terme pour essayer de
limiter la comment je planifie pour
aller à long TER avant tout ça avant
tout ça la gifle de bûcheron tous ces
planquets qui n'ont rien vu venir et qui
continuent de
parler ça dégage une petite session de
livreur de pizza ça va un petit peu les
réchauffer non oui alors après
on non moi jeux dire on peut dire on
dégage maintenant la la question c'est
tu fais quoi pour les dégager tu fais
une liste des gens tu te dis toi tu as
fauté toi tu as fauté toi tu as fauté et
alors il restera Quiés il s' libér la
place par exemple a des jeunes comme
maroundh bah par exemple mais parce que
aujourd'hui attends je dire aujourd'hui
les gens qui font des tribunes pour dire
que le système se plante notamment en
terme de question énergétique c'est
quand même des gens qui étaient aux
manettes c'est qui je je pense qu'il y a
une tribune très récemment sur les gens
disant ce qui se passe avec le programme
nucléaire c'est dramatique mais ces gens
à un moment on avait quand même les
capacités de décider ils étaient auprès
des cercles de pouvoir pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils ont pas alerté plutôt pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a pas réussi à arrêter la
tendance et pourquoi s'ils arrivent pas
à arrêter la tendance ils ont pas
démissionné en disant publiquement ça va
mal on se met en danger on y va dire que
on est dans le mur quand tu étais au
manettees 20 ans plus tard excuse-moi
mais c'est moi j'ai envie de dire c'est
du fooutage joger j'ai envie de dire les
boomers restez dans vos épades et
laissez-nous prendre les commandes alors
laissez-nous prendre les commandes c'est
pas spécialement moi parce que je suis
pas plus compétente que les autres et
sur ce dossierl et est-ce que j'aurais
fait mieux à leur place je suis pas
certaine mais c'est il y a des gens qui
ont des idées en France et qui peuvent
faire des choses et je pense que la la
réponse elle est nécessairement
collective elle viendra même pas d'un
parti politique parce que les partis
politiques aujourd'hui ils sont ils sont
fraise mais ce sont des gens qui
collectivement auront envie de faire
quelque chose pour la France et pour la
France pas pour leurs intérêts et
aujourd'hui faire un truc pour la France
et accepter de se prendre des saut de
merde sur Twitter et de se faire
insulter dans la rue et de mener des
réformes qui sont qui sont difficiles
parce que oui il y a pas assez d'État
mais pour qu'il y ait plus d'État il va
falloir interroger aujourd'hui comment
on fait la dépense publique l'efficacité
de la dépense publique qui on rémunère
comment on le fait justement et ça va
appeler des réformes des réformes
structurelles et pour faire des réformes
structurelles et ben il faut accepter
d'aller construire un consensus et pour
construire un consensus et ben il faut
accepter le rapport de force et se taper
dessus qui aujourd'hui est prêt à
assumer le rapport de France ne
serait-ce qu'en France je te parle même
pas à l'échelle européenne et j'en parle
même pas par rapport à ce qu'il va
falloir conduire face à la Chine et aux
États-Unis parce que dès qu'on parle
aujourd'hui de mettre par exemple une
mesure anti-dumping aux frontières
européennes on nous répond ah bah les
Chinois vont rétorquer de manière plus
forte mais à un moment on ne va pas
reconstruire la puissance de la France
et de l'Europe sans casser des œufs
enfin et tout le monde va payer le prix
mais si on paye pas le prix maintenant
on paiera beaucoup plus cher dans dans
20 ou 30 ans avant voir avant de deux
questions pour toi la première c'est où
est passé l'esprit de sacrifice pour le
pays la deuxème c'est comment
facile la la deuxième c'est où sont
passé les capacités capacité de
projection de la
France si c'était très français capacité
mais on s'est compris l'esprit de
service on l' on l'esprit de service de
sacrifice de sacrifice oh les les les
les les deux peuvent être liés je pense
euh parce que de toute façon la la
politique comment on dit en français ce
mot abnégation abnégation c'est un joli
mot euh de toute façon la la politique
soit on est prêt à une vraie abnégation
soit ça ça ça finit mal euh
mais en fait c'est déjà lié au fait que
la France est un pays extrêmement
centralisé auprès de certaines élites
que la 5e République elle-même en fait
quand on revient au fondamentaux est un
système qui est assez risqué parce que
il est extrêmement pyramidal et que le
général de Gaulle pour réussir et a
raison à l'époque mais à compenser si
vous voulez les sousbressau lié à la
politique politicienne au fait que le
gouvernement peut changer tous les 3
mois tous les 6 mois a créé au sein de
l'État les grands corps d'état les grand
corps d'état à qui il a donné la charge
des projets d'intérêt général et c'est
eux par exemple qui ont alors même que
le gouvernement les présidents la
constition a changé ont réussi à mener
le plan nucléaire français le TGV sur 30
40 ans seulement voilà c'est grands
corps d'état une fois que le père
fondateur a disparu et surtout une fois
que tout que des politiciens d'envergure
qui ont la volonté politique ont disparu
et donc ils se sont retrouvés un peu
vraiment sans contrepouvoir et qu'ils
ont commencé au tournant des années 80 à
adhérer progressivement à cette logique
beaucoup plus financière beaucoup plus
mondialiste et à abandonné un peu la la
vision de défense des intérêts de la
France vous vous allez péter tout le
système parce que vous leur avez
tellement mis entre leurs mains que il
suffit qu'il y en ait quelques-uns qui
draillent ils sont au sommet de vos
administrations ils sont au sommet de
vos grandes entreprises et donc la
machine entière va dérailler et et c'est
ce qu'on a vu je pense qu'il y a
aujourd'hui une méconnaissance très
forte de la part de ces élites là du
reste du territoire ce sont d'ailleurs
raphaë gluxman lui-même le le disait
très honnêtement il disait je me sens
plus proche de de New York que du Cantal
et c'est un problème ben il a raison moi
je me sens plus proche du Cantal que New
York exactement mais parmi les d'élite
il y en a probablement beaucoup moins
cercle d'élite dans le Cantal attention
il a ah je il y a des élites partout
mais le l'autre problème c'est où sont
passés les les capacités d'action et ben
là aussi ça dépend des gens que vous
recrutez il y a une perte terrible
d'attractivité de la politique de la
fonction publique et donc aujourd'hui
vous recrutez les meilleurs s'en vont
pour vous donner un un exemple simple
les grands corps d'état à l'époque hein
c'était quand vous sortiez de
Polytechnique on considérait pas que
vous étiez un ingénieur on considérait
que vous pouviez en Deven ir un et donc
ensuite vous rentriez par exemple dans
le corps des Ponts et là vous allez
commencer une formation de 10 15 ans où
on va vous faire travailler dans le
dénagement des route en haut de Savoie
et puis on va vous faire travailler dans
un port et puis dans la construction
d'un pont et cetera et au bout de 20 ans
vous revenez en cabinet ministériel et
là vous êtes formé vous avez une vraie
expérience aujourd'hui pour de très
nombreuses raisons dont la
décentralisation dont le fait que les
meilleurs vont dans le privé la finance
le conseil et cetera on va parachuter
des jeunes qui connaissent rien au
sommet de l'État et donc en fait eux ils
sont là ils sont au sommet de l'État ils
veulent uniquement une vision court
terme parfois même uniquement aller dans
le privé moi on m'avait proposer un
poste en cabinet ministériel à
l'éducation nationale et et le dircab
m'avait dit ah bah tiens viens ça fera
une bonne ligne sur ton CV si tu restes
un ou 2 ans si ensuite tu veux aller
dans le privé à partir du moment où on
vous présente comme ça dès le début
voyez bien un peu le problème d'ailleurs
la durée de pentouflage moyen je crois
dans les années il faudrait que je
vérifie maises 70 pour un nénarc il
fallait 17 ans et demi en moyenne et
aujourd'hui pour ceux qui passent
cabinet c'est 3 ans donc voilà et donc à
partir de là vous perdez la compétence
vous perdez la vision vous avez des gens
de plus en plus jeunes dans les cabinets
qui et je l'ai vu sont de plus en plus
influençables aussi par les lobbyes
parce que ils arrivent là ils sont
jeunes ils ont pas l'expérience mais
Maroun tu as 25 ans oui bah du coup je
sais de quoi influençableis qui par
pourquoi tu es moins influençable
qu'est-ce qu'ils font papa et maman pour
t'avoir endurci la tête comme ça ah non
ils sont pas ils sont pas dans ces truc
là mais eu comment ils font quoi mon
père fait de l'informatique et ma mère
nous élèv on est si six
enfants es résilient et robuste j'ai
j'ai voulu me essayer de me donner en
profitant des richesses du système
français justement l'armature
intellectuelle et et je ne le dois qu'à
l'école française je le dois à des
choses qui existent encore aujourd'hui
qui sont qui sont les lycées qui sont la
prépa qui sont les grandes écoles et qui
permettent de se former mais aussi je
pense que et et et ça vient du fait que
je suis un passionné d'histoire et donc
que j'ai une admiration pour ce que la
France a pu faire a su faire et je me
suis dit comment ça se fait que l'on
savait construire 20 centrales
nucléaires en 10 ans et aujourd'hui on
arrive plus à en faire une en 20 ans
comment ça se fait qu'on avait le
meilleur réseau de métro du monde
aujourd'hui on narrive pas à boucler le
Grand Paris comment ça se fait que le
TGV en 66 quand on a vu qu'on était en
train de se faire la SNCF il éit en
train de se faire dépasser par l'avion
par la bagnole et par les Japonais et
par les Japonais qui avaient fait un TR
à grande vitesse il lance le projet en
66 en 71 5 ans plus tard on leur met 100
kmh on le met exactement et ça on savait
le faire pourquoi on savait le faire
parce que depuis la 4e République on
avait investi dans des centres de
recherche et développement parce qu'il y
avait le ministère de l'Équipement parce
qu'au sein de la SNCF on savait aussi
investir donc quand Pisani a lancé le
plan 5 ans plus tard on avait le
meilleur train du monde analice est-ce
qu'on peut parler de géopolitique on
peut essayer Trump qui arrive les
Allemands qui sont en train de se
décomposer siingping qui s'énerve les
contrats de sous-marins français avec
Ancus l'Afrique qui nous
déteste on fait quoi elle fait quoi la
Petite France
elle se retous les manches
voilà dit comme ça non mais elle fait
quoi la Petite France B enfin
honnêtement si si la réponse elle était
simple si elle était si tu vois on se
disait la baguette magique ça existe on
pourrait faire quelque chose aujourd'hui
on est l'argent magique l'argent non
l'argent magique on a connu ça au moment
du covid je te rappelle don pas de
blague là-dessus
euh non la la la qu'est-ce qu'elle fait
la Petite France al déjà la Petite
France elle est dans le contexte
européen et je pense que elle doit
travailler et conduire ce rapport de
force à l'échelle européenne et
d'ailleurs on peut même se poser la
question aujourd'hui si est-ce qu'on
reste dans l'Europe alors moi je je
pense que je l'aurais dit à chaque fois
je 9 mai je veux dire j'ai grandi avec
l'Europe je suis plutôt favorable à
l'Europe et je dirai jamais et je sais
qu'il y a des gens qui sont pour le
frxit et qui m'aiment bien et je vous
aime bien aussi mais je ne vous dirai
jamais que je suis pour le frxit je
pense pas que la France s'en sortira
mieux surtout si tu considères qu'on est
un pays avec pas mal de branquignol
qu'on s'en sortira mieux en dehors de l'
s'appelle pas la la scoreb nation en
terme d'intelligence économique de
renseignement moi j'appelle plus ça
j'appelle plus ça un corps d'élite ou
mais je veux dire c'est à partir du
moment où tu fais ce constat tu te dis
en dehors de l'Europe je je je te dire
aujourd'hui on bénéficie de choses parce
qu'on on est encore dans dans dans
l'Europe qu'on a on a l'Euro et exemples
on bénéfici de quoi non mais tu tu on
bénéficie de quoi
non ouais la défense européenne n'existe
pas l'énergie le le l'énergie je veux
dire aujourd'hui on a le marché européen
on a le seul truc qu'on arrive encore à
exporter en France c'est quand même de
l'électricité oui ça s'appelle le plan
que Pompidou et zambber faitou mais mais
je veux dire ok mais tu tu pars de de de
de de de tout ça et tu te dis ok on a on
a on a dilapidé beaucoup de choses
pourquoi on n pas capable de faire un un
PR parce qu'on a arrêté d'en faire
pendant X années donc Paron a plus de
soudeur mais pas que parce qu'on a plus
de soudeur quand ça fait des années que
tu ne fais plus quelque chose quand tu
te dis qu'il faut faut le refaire
forcément réacquérir les technologies
reformer les gens recréer la filière et
cetera ça ça prend du temps de la même
manière que on prête polémique et se
dire est-ce que le Pr est le bon modèle
est-ce que aujourd'hui si on sait plus
faire ça dans un temps court est-ce
qu'il faut pas aller chercher des
technologies qui sont implémentables
beaucoup plus rapidement à l'étranger et
reconstruire notre capacité dire on vit
on vit sur des choses en France on fait
des trucs incroyables on a fait le
Rafale on fait des pr ça se vend pas et
c'est compliqué on a mis de l'ingénieur
du produit parfait le produit parfait
c'est pas forcément le produit qui se
vend une fois qu'on a dit ça qu'est-ce
qu'on fait et ben je crois qu'il y a des
gens qui en France envie de faire des
choses que ça soit des citoyens des
chefs d'entreprise des syndicalistes et
même des politiques et ces gens-là
doivent travailler ensemble au-delà leur
clivage à reconstruire la France et dans
le cadre européen et dans le cadre
européen s assumer les rapports de force
alors Maroun dira peut-être autre chose
et ça sera un point de désaccord et j'ai
pas de problème làdessus vas-y tu veux
la fenêre de tir maintenant moi j'ai
j'ai des bémoles quand même sur l'Europe
je pense qu'il faut faire attention att
non mais c'est pas parce que tu es pour
l'Europe que tu dis pas que l'Europe
fonctionne bien moi je dis pas que la
Commission européenne elle fonctionne
bien je dis pas que tout est beau tout
est rose je dis juste que le cadre
européen me semble être un cadre
pertinent notamment pour construire des
politiques industrielles et que l'Europe
doit faire du prote doit faire du
protectionisme il y a un truc qui est
pas concevable on a la question
énergétique on a un autre truc on met
des normes environnemental et social
très élevé et ça c'est une bonne chose
je on est pour par contre quand on parle
de simplifier à tout le monde dit faut
simplifier il y a trop de normes tout il
y a personne qui commencé à faire une
List par le début c'est quoi simplifier
les normes simplifier des normes sans
supprimer est-ce qu'on commencerait pas
par supprimer ou rendre obligatoire les
normes qu'on impose à nos entreprises
c'est-à-dire dire si une norme est bonne
c'est une norme qu'on impose à nos
entreprises et qu'on impose au produits
entrant sur le territoire si on n'impose
pas produits entrant sur le territoire
alors on peut questionner son utilité je
peux poser juste une question bête et
terre à terre allez alors les normes
est-ce que les normes sont adaptées à
nos pauvres quand je vois que ma voiture
va être interdite et est interdite quand
je vois que il y a des normes pour les
machins il y a des ça fait beaucoup de
normes que pour les petits parisiens
mais al l'industrie c'est pareil je
prends un exemple les pauvres en Inde
ils mangent dans la rue dans des street
food tu as déjà essayé de manger les
street food en Inde c'est pas mal pour
le régime c'est 13 kg en une semaine
donc ils ont pas les mêmes normes mais
ils mangent et système gastrique
s'adapte leur leur système immunitaire
aussi et et et parasitaire nous on se
retrouve avec des pauvres en France qui
vont être de plus en plus pauvres qui
vont avoir moins accès à la calorie et
on va leur mettre norme sur norme sur
norme et des industries qui seront pas
compétitif pour le c'est la la bonne ou
la la mauvaise norme et ça c'est le
débat c'est le débat qu'il faut qu'il
faut conduire maintenant sur la question
du véhicule électrique le problème du
véhicule électrique c'est le prix du du
véhicule aujourd'hui
mais le recyclage on peut on on pré
avoir la question et et les
infrastructures et peut-être que c'était
pas le au regard de notre histoire
industriel c'était peut-être pas le
meilleur choix à faire caprice d'colo
pour la subation de vote non je pense
pas que ce soit un caprice d'écolo je
pense juste qu'on on raisonne la
politique de mobilité à travers le
véhicule alors que une politique de
mobilité dans le contexte de la
transition écologique c'est pas que des
bagnoles c'est du transport en commun
donc un réseau ferroviaire c'est du
transport collectif c'est des mobilités
alternatives et je c'est dire on peut
dire qu'on veut le véhicule électrique
pour un certain nombre de de de de
raisons par contre là où il y a il y a
il y a un problématique c'est la norme
européenne elle est plutôt en faveur des
gros véhicules qu'on produit plus sur le
territoire européen pour des questions
de sécurité le débat il faudrait se
pososer de se dire est-ce que on a
besoin de de tout le monde a besoin d'un
SUV non il y a besoin de petits
véhicules est-ce qu'on sait faire des
petits véhicules à prix compétitif en
thermique Toyota sait le faire c'est pas
parce que les constructeurs français
savent pas le faire que un constructeur
japonais c'est pas nous montrer tout
l'exemple qui sait produire des petits
véhicules pr compétitif sur le
territoire le territoire français donc
c'est aussi c'est on peut interroger la
norme dire que la norme elle est absurde
mais la norme elle se construit avec des
gens qui viennent aussi expliquer qu'à
un moment c'est la bonne norme c'est le
rapport de force et lobby et c'est nos
choix industriels et c'est pour ça que
c'est indestricable sans se dire à un
moment c'est tout le monde quiet tout à
plat et qui accepte de prendre sa
responsabilité et son ah bah ça c'est
extrêmement je veux dire démontel tout
le truc aujourd'hui il va falloir
s'accrocher il va falloir de la de la de
la volonté mais il y a un moment il va
falloir dire si vous voulez rentrer sur
le territoire européen c'est tel tarif
vous voulez construire une usine sur le
territoire européen vous les vendre sur
le territoire européen on pourrait très
bien faire des clauses de localisation
comme les américains le font on peut
faire des transferts de technologie je
peux faire l'avocat du diable mais tu
adores faire l'avocat du diable
vas-y moi mes pauvres je vais faire
comment pour les contenter avec des
merdes made in China mais aujourd'hui tu
es en train de les contenter avec des
merdes made in China et tu leur assures
aucun avenir parce que tu n'investis
plus dans les infrastructures tu n
infrastructure routière ferroviaire
infrastructure énergétique tu leur
assures plus des emplois de qualité les
chinois ils font des trucs bien non mais
tu n'assures plus d'emplois de qualité
parce que il y a plus d'usine sur le
territoire national donc en fait
aujourd'hui ils peuvent je dire je vais
simplifier je vais caricaturer à
outrance aujourd'hui ils peuvent encore
acheter des choses m in China demain il
y aura plus d'ascenseur social enfin il
y aura plus de système social et de
transferts sociaux et donc ils ne
pourront plus rien acheter et ceux qui
sont moyennement riches aujourd'hui sont
les les pauvres de demain parce que
l'industrie c'est des emplois de c'est
la capacité à créer des transferts
sociaux c'est de se donner les moyens de
se poser des questions et demain tu as
plus d'industrie mais il faut pas croire
que tout le monde que certains il y en a
quelques-uns qui vont peut-être réussir
à s'en sortir mais tout le monde va va
va dépérir et les produits mais ninchana
il vont venir presque pour certains
inaccessible donc la question du du
pouvoir d'achat elle va se poser chaque
jour qui passe un peu plus frontalement
et et d'ailleurs la question c'est pas
la dette ou le pouvoir d'achat ou la
transition écologique c'est comment on
arrive à résoudre ce triptique dans le
contexte actuel le cercle vicieux dette
pouvoir d'achat det pouvoir d'achat
vieillissement de la population
Maroun on fait quoi dans cette échiqué
géopolitique où il y a les méchants
russes les méchants américains les
méchants chinois les méchants marocains
israéliens et j'en pass il y a que des
méchants et nous on est avec
branquignol déjà effectivement on
reprend en conscience comme disent les
les Américains il y a ni d'ami ni
d'ennemi permanent des intér permanents
on a des gens qui profitent du vide de
pouvoir euh je pense que on a eu
notamment ce ce mythe je reviens sur
l'état de de dire hériter du libéralisme
du 19e siècle et que musk dit beaucoup
en disant si l'État se retire ça fera
plus de liberté pour l'individu mais ça
dans un M globalisé ça marche pas du
tout si l'État se retire juste vous vous
soumettez à d'autres puissances que ce
soit l'Europe les intérêts privés ou les
autres États euh alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait je pense que la France a encore de
nombreux atouts euh dans des secteurs où
les États-Unis vont avoir du mal on voit
par exemple les difficultés de Boeing la
Gal des roir peut-être peut-être qu'ils
en font moins je connais moins le
marchéol non commentoli le C ver le CAM
vert s les cru on est c'est mort c'est
pour ça on est tranquille ouais mais tu
peux pas l'explorter chez eux toute
façon il faut pas exporter de CV aux
États-Unis on donne pas de la confiture
au cochons les
enfants j'adore les
États-Unis le Boeing a des difficultés
Boeing a des difficultés parce que les
États-Unis soumettent toutes leurs
entreprises a une logique financière de
court terme ça marche parfois et ça leur
donne des entreprises extrêmement euh
extrêmement agressive mais qui
fonctionnent extrêmement bien comme les
gfames comme des entreprises notamment
dans le domaine pharmaceutique quand je
dis agressive c'est y compris dans les
conséquences sociales mais bon mais il y
a pas de mé bon dans les conséquences
sociales du point de vue de leur point
de vue je pense qu' je pense qu'il s'en
fichent mais disons enfin je veux dire
qu on voit genre de je sais plus qui
avait fait conférence sur l'A et on lui
a dit les conséquences sociales il a dit
adapt or die ok bon ça c'est une bonne
c'est une vision de darwinisme social
d'accord c'est américain mais Boeing
pourquoi ça marche pas c'est parce que
c'est une industrie où il y a besoin
d'investir dans la maintenance dans la
sécurité dans dans dans l'avion il y a
besoin d'investir dans les tests de
sécurité les matières premières qu'ils
achètent et donc airbus est en train de
les doubler et je pense qu'on a tout un
ensemble d'industries encore en France
aujourd'hui dans les infrastructures
lourdes dans l'industrie lourde les
Veolia les suèes les halstom transport
et cetera dans lesquels les Américains
ne nous rattraperont pas parce que ça ne
les intéresse pas ça n'intéresse pas
leur fond de nous rattraper et la
logique commerciale financière de toute
façon n'y arrivera pas il faut trop de
de de d'investissement de CAPEX les
chinois sont en train d'y arriver bien
sûr mais je pense que on peut développer
il faut se dire toute façon la
consommation grand public il y a des
sujets sur lesquels on a perdu la
bataille en France il faut se
spécialiser sur ce qu'on sait faire le
mieux et la spécialisation ça paye Anaïs
cité TSMC tout à l'heure il y a une île
perdu au milieu de la mer de Chine don
tout le monde s'en fout et qui a réussi
à se spécialiser dans un seul secteur
qui sont les semionducteurs Taiwan
Taiwan ils sont sous le feu des
projecteurs tous les jours justement
parce que initialement dans les années
50 tout le monde s'en fichait de Taiwan
c'est juste l'île où était aller se
réfugier nationaliste chinois est-ce que
tu as étudié comment à l'époque quand
ils ont fait cette mutation industrielle
est-ce que tu as étudié la sociologie
des tawanais comment ils ont prené plein
à la tête le sacrifice qui sont tu as
étudié ça bah le comment il s'appelle
Maurice Maurice Chang je crois à la tête
de
TSMC c'était aussi c'est la même logique
que la reconstruction en France c'était
des combattants il venaient de nulle
part c'est la même logique qu'a eu la
Corée c'est-à-dire que quand il y a rien
quand il y a plus rien quand vous êtes à
zéro déjà vous repérez mieux que ceux
qui sont patriotes parce que vous venez
d'avoir une expérience ça c'est
peut-être un des rares avantages la
guerre mais disons en 44 c'était plus
facile de savoir qu'il était qui nétait
pas et puis surtout en France on était
tous résistants et oui par ailleurs mais
enfin les gens de l'époque le savaient
que non et puis et puis par ailleurs
vous prenez plus de risqu qu'est-ce
qu'on fait Taiwan ils ont réussi à
s'insérer dans le processus de
production de fabrication de l'un des
composantes les plus critiques de
l'empire américain qui sont les
semi-conducteurs ils sont allés voir
Texas Instrument Intel et cetera en leur
disant c'est vous allez quand même
augmenter votre marge si vous faites un
peu d'entreprise sans usine nous on vous
prend les usines ils ont remonté toute
la chaîne de valeur aujourd'hui on peut
plus faire ça en Taiwan ils ont tous les
feux des projecteurs ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que il suffit de quelques
spécialisations qui sont bien calibrées
et je pense qu'on peut avoir quand même
un poid important là où il faut faire
attention et notamment se méfier aussi
de l'Europe c'est que par exemple ce
qu'on sait faire très bien c'est les
trains par exemple exp on exporte bien à
New Delhi au k à Sao Paulo et C 21 21 %
des exportations non je parle sous le
contrôle je j'ai pas le chiffre mais en
tout cas les trains les métos on sait
très bien les exporter on a voulu en
2019 fusionner Alstom et Siemens
transport et faire ainsi un champion
européen du transport ferroviaire
notamment pour faire face à la
concurrence chinoise à CRC qui était le
l'acteur chinois qui a refusé ce leader
du couple franco-allemand c'est
Bruxelles c'est union européenne qui a
dit non ça vous pouvez pas le faire
alors même que l'Europe initialement
c'est elle-même construite sur des
fusions industrielles du même type
pourquoi parce que Bruxelles est habité
aussi pénétré par les lobbyes c'est la
capitale mondiale des lobbyes dont une
grande majorité sont américains pas
forcément pour le gouvernement américain
mais aussi pour les entreprises
américaines et c'est le rêve des lobby
Bruxelles parce que vous avez plus 28
parlements à convaincreis tu sais les éc
tu sais où les écouter les lobbyistes
bruxellois non ah si tu sais peut-être
en face il y a plein de barres c'est là
où ils vont ensuite sinon il y a le
quartier ch de Bruxelles c'est très
intéressant d'aller prêter l'oreille
quand ils sont un peu avinés continue
c'est très facile en fait parce que vous
avez pas de volonté politique forte vous
avez tout un ensemble de de gens qui
sont plutôt des des technocrates et puis
derrière vous pouvez imposer aux règles
nationales et on a par exemple les
cabinets de conseil qui ont réussi à se
créer eux-mêmes des marchés en imposant
aux entreprises des reportings notamment
ESG dont l'influence je pense sur la
vraie transition écologique est très
faible sinon négative parce que vous
avez des entreprises qui juste
produisent des PowerPoint et qui font
comme si ell faisaient quelque chose et
c'est une taxe que l'on impose à toutes
les entreprises européennes donc
françaises une taxe qui part à ses
cabinets qui ont réussi à convaincre
quelques décideurs à Bruxelles que
toutes les entreprises doivent payer ça
et donc ils se nourrissent sur la bête
donc je pense moi je je crois dans le
fait qu'on a besoin de nos partenaires
européens je pense qu'il faut faire
attention au cadre européen actuel à ce
qu'il nous impose et à ce qu'on se
laisse imposer aussi par notre naïveté
anï est-ce qu'on est trop naïf euh
assurément assurément alors je pense que
en France on est trop naïf je suis pas
convaincu que les Allemands soient trop
naïfs je pense juste qu'on a on a encore
une fois tu me répètes mais des intérêts
largement largement
divergent on est naïf et et je crois
que il y a une sorte
de parfois j'eni presque se dire que on
avait pas
assez dans une une situation
catastrophique pour rebondir parce qu'on
bénéficie encore d'un certain nombre
d'avantages et de choses qui sont
héritées hérité du passé et euh si tu
veux il y a pas le le le coup de fouet
ne vient pas la la notion d'urgence il
faut réagir et maintenant il est temps
de de de redresser le braquet ne vient
pas sinon je je suis pas convaincu tu
vois on est on est vraiment la situation
politique vie aujourd'hui en France elle
est vraiment le signe qu'on est dans un
dans un monde qui se pe qui se meurt on
a des fondamentaux qui sont en train de
disparaître en Occident et en
particulier en Europe le le le les les
les le bariccentre du monde là où les
décisions se prennent les rapport de
force sont en train de changer et en
fait on en a peut-être pas encore
totalement pris conscience en Europe
parce qu'on a d'une certaine manière
encore quelques marges de manœuvre c'est
à partir du moment où on se rendra
compte qu'on a vraiment plus de capacité
à agir que là il sera il sera il sera
trop tard mais je crois que les Français
ont vraiment besoin de se
retrouver parler un peu crument dans la
merde pour rebondir et tu vas me dire on
est dans la merde mais je suis pas
convaincu que tout le monde et notamment
dans les décideurs ressentent
aujourd'hui à quel point la situation du
pays est est critique tu as globalement
tu as l'illusion que les choses
fonctionnent et on essaie toujours de se
rassurer en se disant euh ça va mal
jusqu'ici tout va bien mais
euh déjà vu un Cham tu sais tu sais le
jour où il y aura des coupures
d'électricité en France ce qui a failli
se produire au moment de la crise
énergétique là les gens vont prendre
conscience que les choses vont vraiment
mal or aujourd'hui on a une résilience
du système qui fait queon n'est pas
arrivé à cet extrême- làà et en fait le
le système arrive encore à être
relativement résilient et ceux qui
pâtissent pleinement de la dégradation
de la situation ne sont pas les gens qui
sont visibles dans l'espace public dans
l'espace médiatique et même dans les
cercles de décision donc des coupures
d'électricité des ruptures de chaînes
d'approvisionnement alimentaire quoi
d'autre rupture rupture
d'approvisionation
ù les G ilura une systétisation la
fermure des services d'urg où on va
vraiment publiqu ça va vraiment se voir
qu'il y a des choix de malade parce que
le système sera à bout de souffle à
partir du moment où on pourra plus
accéder à à certains biens de grande
consommation parce qu'ils seront devenus
trop chers c'est des choses comme ça qui
qui
vont nous nous nous obliger à à rebondir
on est je décrit presque un un un
effondrement mais je je veux pas être
plus pessimiste qu'il faudrait l'être
parce que je suis pas convaincu parce
que je je suis pas convaincu que la peur
soit un
moteur la peur elle a un moteur qui te
qui va à la rigueur accentuer les
comportements individuels pour sauver
euh pour sauver Guer la guerre est un
moteur bah la guerre elle te donne pas
le choix la guerre je parle en
production industrielle ah bah on parle
d'économie de guerre avec ce qui se
passe en en Ukraine bien entendu euh la
la la la l'industrie de la défense
française marche beaucoup mieux depuis
qu'il y a la guerre en en Ukraine et
qu'on est dans un contexte géopolitique
où tout le monde tend à se se réarmer et
on se dit que tous les jours on craint
qu'il y
ait un une phénomène de contamination ça
a été quand euh il y a eu les les les
attentats en Israël ça a été euh
l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
c'est la crainte de l'invasion de Taiwan
par par la Chine
c'est Donald Trump au Grenland mais
d'ailleurs Donald Trump au Grenland la
réaction est super intéressante du
Danemark comment danemar ou je suis prêt
à discuter d'où tu es prêt à discuter
avec quelqu'un qui qui qui commence à à
questionner ta ta souveraineté ils ont
aucun
choix ils ont aucun choix financièrement
technologiquement militairement les
États-Unis peuvent éteindre leur pays du
jour au lendemain dans ce caslà c'est
quoi la réponse tu fais un aveu
d'impuissance et tu dis l'Europe c'est
terminé rideau Pipo il y a plus il y a
plus rien à faire on est foutu à partir
du moment où tu dis qu'un pays européen
est impuissant parce que je suis pas
convaincu que la France elle est plus
oui mais je veux bien Danemark tu crois
que la France est plus en mesure d'aller
sououtre sur la tronche avec les
États-Unis si on leur interdit le
cbert non mais on est on les sanctionne
on est aujourd'hui dansation là là là là
c'est ça c'est faire l'avocat du diable
gen
d'accord et on fait des mesures à
postérior quand ils ont bien détruit
notre notre industrie et on se dit et on
se dit finalement le droit de la
concurrence comme il est est très bien
mais mais on peut
pas là quand tu dis ça tu dis on est
foutu et déménageons tous ailleurs alors
ça c'est la question qui se pose en ce
moment est-ce qu'il faut les les
Français c'est ce qui dans nos cercles
c'est c'est un bruit de fond qui est en
train de remonter très fort l' rau qui
se Ba qui se casse la figure face à
audllar les perspectives industrielles
et économiques de l'Europe la jeune
génération française on va commencer à
partir de Maroun a un peu de poil au mon
il a de trois idées il s'intéresse aux
choses est encore jeune non il termine
sur serw parce qu'il a un gros
cerveau est-ce que cette génération là
de jeunes entrepreneurs avec un gros
cerveau est-ce qu'elle est condamnée à
crever avec la France et l'Europe ou
est-ce qu'il faut qu'elle se barre pour
pouvoir revenir
elle est la France moi je veux dire les
les c'est autoréalisateur c'est-à-dire
que si tout le monde part on a perdu si
les gens restent on peut faire quelque
chose simplement il faut il faut bien
analyser les choses il faut donner il
faut donner au meilleurs à ceux qui ont
vraiment l'ambition les chances il faut
par exemple pour les entreprises pour
les start-ups arrêter de financer
simplement celles qui obéissent à un
modèle financier ou parce que le type
est sorti d'achc il faut valoriser les
start-ups industriels ceux qui savent
faire des des vraies choses mais
derrière oui enfin je veux dire on on va
a créer notre propre destin et si on
part tous je pense qu'on a perdu c'est
pour ça qu'il faut faire très attention
à ce bruit de fond qui donne la France
perdante avant de l'êre même quand on
est dans une situation de dépendance
totale on peut se redresser le Japon en
1945 la la le niveau de dépendance par
rapport aux États-Unis était était était
sidérant je veux dire rarement un pays
avec la Corée on atteint de tel niveau
de dépendance dans les années 70 juste
un détail tu connais le mot en japonais
qui dit mourir de travail non ils ont un
mot pour dire mourir de travail Kochi
oui c'est pas la même culture évidemment
mais il faut déjà rapporter à la
productivité on a su être extrêmement
productif en France notamment dans des
secteurs à haute valeur ajoutée et puis
il y a aussi le fait que je pense que la
France la France bénéficie encore de
nombreux atouts que d'autres pays n'ont
pas y compris l'Allemagne c'est-à-dire
qu'on a des atouts énergétiques bien sûr
on a notre puissance nucléaire
hydroélectrique mais on la possède
encore on a encore des savoir faire on a
encore des écoles qui savent former les
gens simplement on narrive plus à les
recruter vous avez environ 80000
français dans la Silicon valallleée et
il manque 80000 ingénieur informaticien
en France bah ils existent c'estàdire
que c'est plus rapide que si on doit
former tout le monde refaire un système
éducatif de zéro simplement comment on
se donne perdant avant et notamment
parce que on a une certaine élite
politicofinancière qui a décidé que le
modèle français était desués et qui nous
a donné perdant il y a déjà 20 ans et
donc il a tout fait pour que
effectivement on le devienne bah et là
on rejoint le patriotisme ça veut dire
que et et c'est le drame notamment euh
il y a comment il s'appelle Milosevic
qui est un grand auteur
sociologue américain justement et qui
analyse les pays les anciennes colonies
et il dit leur drame c'est qu'ils ont
des élites qui méprisent leur propre
pays et qui n'arrête pas de regarder
vers la métropole l'ancienne colonie
parce que il rêverait de faire partie de
cette ancienne colonie et on commence à
avoir un peu euh la la même dynamique en
France c'est-à-dire qu'on a des élites
qui se rêvent être américaines ou en
tout cas qui se rêvent être des
démocrates américain et donc ils vont
regarder vers les États-Unis parfois
même il finir et et derrière c'est comme
ça qu'on perd aussi notre notre façon de
faire vous avez même si on revient dans
les écoles ça dépend ce qu'on met dans
la tête des gens mais HC il y a 30 ans
formé à ce qu'on appelle le management
public c'est-à-dire la gestion des
grandes entreprises françaises
aujourd'hui le programme a complètement
changé tous les cours sont en anglais et
il vous forment uniquement à intégrer
des fonds d'investissement des banques
d'affaires et des cabinés de conseil
américains et on prend directement on
vous expose le PDF du MIT en disant an
voilà ça c'est ce que vous devez
apprendre donc évidemment si on commence
à coloniser les esprits d'ailleurs on va
avoir du mal à à se
ressaisir je je je de toute façon la la
la réponse elle appelle aussi au choix
individuel et à notre volonté de servir
la France parce que il y a une simple
bonne raison pourquoi les ingénieurs
français vont dans la silicone Vallé bah
parce que Google les gfemmes de manière
générale offrent des salaires qu'on
n'est pas capable d'offrir dans
l'industrie et là on se ramène à un
sujet de de
spécialisation que les Américains ont et
qu'on et qu'on a pas la deuxième chose
audelà du salaire c'est je pense il a la
capacité d'innover qui et la volonté
d'innover qui est peut-être plus forte
aujourd'hui aux États-Unis ou en Asie
que ce qu'on a en France et que quand on
est un ingénieur et quand en plus on a
envie de faire de la recherche et d'être
dans l'innovation et ben c'est peut-être
pas en France où ça se passe parce qu'on
voit qu'on a quand même une stagnation
des dépenses dans dans dans ce
domaineelà donc il y a un moment il y a
un choix conscient qui est de dire euh
je renonce à un salaire pour euh servir
mon pays et et l'autre chose c'est que
encore une fois et on finit à la DRM
c'est ça mais non tu finis non non mais
non mais en fait le truc c'est que
reconstruire le pays c'est avoir des
gens compétents et on en a déjà au sein
de l'État et pour mais mais bien entendu
en fait on a des gens compétents partout
on a on a même je pense qu'on a même
certaines réponses à nos problèmes vu la
quantité de rapport qu'on produit la
question c'est d'avoir une vision
d'avoir un cap et qu'on soit capable de
le porter collectivement et aussi
accepter que le monde qu'on a connu
n'existera plus le monde se reconfigure
et Lamot elle met le chocolat dans le
papier d'aluminium mais non mais tu peux
tu peux dire ça mais il y a il y a exprè
ouais mais je je je veux dire il y a un
moment le le la France Golon pom
bidonienne c'est terminé ça n'existera
plus parce que c'était dans un cadre de
reconstruction du pays on était pas
encore dans dans l'Europe la
mondialisation n'était pas ce qu'elle
était donc on arrête de se tourner vers
le passé on prend acte du futur de de ce
que va être le futur des nouvelles R
nouvelle réalité et rivalité
géopolitique du fait qu'il y a une
concurrence intra et extra européenne du
fait que nos concurrents d'hier ne sont
pas ceux de demain et que le monde
occidental qui s'est rêvé comme le
centre du monde parce qu'il se voyait
comme un gros grand lieu d'innovation et
B est en train de de de perdre ça parce
qu'il y a d'autres qui innovent plus que
nous qui ont une vision et une
trajectoire qui est très claire et à
partir du moment où tu as fait ton deuil
du passé et tu es prêt à reconstruire le
futur tu as déjà une base si se dire se
dire on va refaire comme ce qu' a fait
de Go les Pompidou ça ne marchera pas ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas de
planification c'est une planification
qui va changer ça veut dire que c'est
peut-être pas les secteurs sur lesquels
on a misé à cette époque là qui sont les
bons ce sont des des des secteurs futurs
on peut parler de la robotique
industrielle on peut parler de
l'intelligence artificiel il y a il y a
peut-être 4 C secteurs et pas 10 c'est
pas 34 sur lesquels il faut miser en se
disant la France sera la championne
demain là-dedans et la dette si c'est de
la dette pour l'investissement et pour
le fut futur c'est pas forcément de la
mauvaise dette et et et et et c'est ça
il faut construire ce cap on peut se
dire tout va mal c'est je dire il y a
plein de gens qui vont dire oh les
tartte à la crème cette expression elle
est
naïveelle elle nous dit pas mais si un
moment si tu as un moment tu as pas un
cap et tu sais pas ce que tu veux
construire collectivement et si tu le
portes pas dans tes tripes et le porter
dans tes tripes c'est aussi dire à
l'école c'est ça notre cap c'est que les
entreprises se mettent au service de
tout le monde que l'administration soit
orientée là-dessus que les politiques
soit convaincu c'estàd le cap il doit
dépasser les guares d'ego politiques il
est une orientation d'une nation c'est
ça qu'on doit c'est ça qu'on doit
reconstruire si tu me dis je vais faire
un peu de politique industrielle et
cetera ben demain j'ai un changement de
majorité euh je vais avoir un autre truc
industriel ça ne marchera pas il faut un
projet fédérateur qui donne envie aux
gens de se lever le matin et de se dire
je suis pas qu'au service de mone
salaire je suis au service d'un pays et
ça c'est une vision et c'est des gens
qui doivent la la la la porter et euh
c'est pas un homme c'est pas une femme
c'est un collectif qui se dit la France
elle vaut mieux que ce qu'on est en
train d'en faire ah quand je t'entends
j'ai l'impression d' entendre l'Institut
des hautes études à la Défense
nationale semer ses graines de la
défense française dans chaque cerveau
français il faut faire ça aussi pour
l'industrie
Maroun est-ce que tu veux rajouter
quelque chose oui je me disais je pense
ça dépend aussi de là où on met notre
reconnaissance ça c'est très important
il y a une vraie politique de la
reconnaissance c'està-dire reconnaître
les gens qui travaillent réellement
reconnaître les ingénieurs reconnaître
on parlait de l'apprentissage on parlait
de pizza aussi les infirmières ce que
pendant boulangers un petit moment de
grâce on a reconnu ou dit reconnaître
pendant le covid ceux qu'on a applaudi
en disant ça c'est les métiers
essentiels il faont tourner le pays et
puis bon après on les a oublié pourquoi
c'est important parce que il y a le
salaire mais il y a aussi est-ce que
c'est valorisé et il suffit de regarder
2 minutes en Chine c'est c'est c'est
dingue ils organisent à chenzen par
exemple ils amènent tous les étudiants
en licence d'ingénierie de robotique et
cetera ils leur font faire des combats
de robots vous pouvez avoir 40000 50000
personnes qui regardent ceux qui sont
médaillés ils sont médaillés devant tout
le monde ils ont un poste à dji qui est
la
principale entreprise de de de drone
dans le monde et donc derrière ils
reconnaissent ces gens-là et ça ce qu'on
savait faire en France aussi et les
grands corps d'état ont pu positivement
servir à ça c'est que dans les années 60
70 un type qui rejoignait Airbus c'était
un héros c'était un type qui savait
faire voler des avions F aussi et EDF
évidemment et en terme de compéten et
ben le gars il s s btir des centrales
nucléaires donc nous qu'est-ce qu'on
sait faire je sais pas lui il sait faire
ça et donc et et pour revenir à au côté
de de GO les Pompidou je pense qu'il
faut il faut pas tourner la page trop
vite non plus parce que il faut qu'on la
lise bien il faut qu'on lise bien ce
qu'on savait faire et ce qu'on savait
pas faire ce qui se dit aujourd'hui
c'est ouais mais il y a eu plein
d'échecs industriels comme le Minitel
comme le Plan Calcul et ceter min c'est
vachement bien en fait oui oui mais ça
c'est juste pas exporter qu'est-ce qui a
qu'est-ce qui a manqué par exemple dans
le Minitel c'est que vous avez deux
branches dans l'innovation vous avez
l'innovation de long terme dans lequel
seul l'état peut investir par exemple
les robots qu'on voit du Boston Dynamics
là qui dansse et tout ça a commencé
l'investissement en 1986 d'accord donc
il y a 40 ans li a idem dans les années
80 même même avant enfin c'est des
investissements sur 30 40 ans le tunnel
sous la Manche c'est 30 ans ça c'est
l'État qui le prend en charge et ça la
France savait très bien le faire et
c'est pour ça qu'on a eu le Concorde
c'est pour ça qu'on a eu le mirage c'est
pour ça qu'on a eu le Minitel le TGV ce
qu'on savait beaucoup moins faire par
contre et Anaïs l' l'a dit c'est on
manquait d'entrepreneurs capable de
reprendre ses innovations et
et de les transformer en des biens de
consommation de masse par exemple un
type comme Steve Jobs qui reprend des
innovations de l'État américain de
l'armée américaine de la DARPA que sont
le GPS que sont l'écran tactile aussi
des universités américaines de la
recherche publique et qui arrivent à les
mettre ensemble ce qu'on appelle
uneiversation architecturale c'estàdire
que vous créez rien juste vous combinez
des choses existantes pour en faire un
bien de consommation ça c'est ce qui
nous manquait qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on
s'est dit ah benah comme le Minitel ça
pas fonctionn et cetera bah le ministère
de l'Industrie on va supprimer le
ministère de l'Équipement on va
supprimer et donc on a saboté la jambe
qui fonctionnait et et on n pas on n pas
réussi à développer l'autre et donc on a
perdu on a perdu sur les les deux plans
et et moi ça me fend le cœur quand
aujourd'hui on dit oui mais la France en
fait c'est un pays où on s'est pas
innover où les Allemands d'ailleurs
commencent à se dire la même chose en
voyant les États-Unis mais on est parmi
les pays où où sont nés la révolution
industrielle c'estàdire que on a une
liste d'innovations qui sont qui qui
sont longues comme le bras mais
simplement aujourd'hui effectivement on
a saboté le le moteur de long terme qui
est notamment l'investissement public et
l'autre on sait toujours pas très bien
le faire anal un sujet à rajouter
ou vous pouvez nous faire la lecture de
vot je peux faire une lecture avec une
voix swive de mon magnifique ouvrage que
voici que je vous recommande il
s'appelle pour une révolution
industrielle et il va falloir une voix
sacrément ch pour pouvoir non alors non
mais pour pour pour le coup je vais
faire un disclaimer ça ne parle ni de
compétitivité ni
de nor pourquoi pour simple et bonne
raison que je crois que l'industrie elle
doit revenir au cœur de nos sociétés et
pour qu'elle revienne au cœur de nos
sociétés il faut s'interroger dans quel
projet de société on la met aujourd'hui
tout le monde est convaincu qu'il faut
réindustrialiser la France je mettre
comme ça comme ça on va vraiment
optimiser la page de pub tout le monde
est convaincu sur du fait qu'il faut
fait la mise au point qu'il faut
réindustrialiser la France néanmoins on
sait pas pourquoi on veut le faire on
sait pas comment on veut le faire on
nassume pas le fait que l'industrie est
un outil de puissance et tout simplement
parce qu'on a pas cette notion de projet
de société et qu'on a un imaginaire
autour de l'industrie qui est assez
négatif et on parlait des métiers qui
étaient déconsidérés et il y a un truc
qui revient souvent quand on parle
d'industrie c'est de dire si tu
travailles mal à l'école tu as finir à
l'usine et je crois qu'en fait en
apprentissage ou en apprentissage mais
le sujet le sujet c'est c'est pas tant
l'industrie c'est la représentation
qu'on a de certaines catégories sociales
on est ingénieur chez Airbus on est
directeur d'une usine je crois que ça
reste socialement valorisé par contre on
est ouvrier sur une ligne de production
c'est aussi peu considéré qu'un certain
nombre d'autres métiers parce que
derrière ça c'est la catégorie
socio-professionnelle du monde ouvrier
qu'on qu'on critique et dont on
s'éloigné et donc dans toute cette
question d'imaginaire elle est un
élément clé pour inscrire l'industrie de
manière durable alors ça revient c'est
pas à travers l'entrée de la puissance
de la souveraineté mais c'est un autre
moyen d'ancrer cette question
industrielle et donner aussi envie envie
aux gens de s'intéresser à l'industrie
pourquoi on a besoin d'industrie ne
serait-ce que si on n'est pas convaincu
par la souveraineté de se dire que si on
veut continuer à consommer un peu près
librement un moment va falloir payer le
prix environnement mental et social de
nos choix et qu' a pas de raison de
confier n notre merdier aux autres il va
falloir l'assumer sinon on arrête de
l'importer un petit paragraphe pour
lecture ah mais attends j'ai pas préparé
n'importe lequel au pif donne un numéro
de page
38 non est nul 71 non vas-y je vais
prendre la conclusion la dernière le
dernier si si si si
euh voilà certains considéreront qu'il
s'agit d'une utopie donc la
réindustrialisation mais a l'air de la
quête du sens donner son énergie pour
faire bouger les lignes et faire
adevenir de nouveaux modèles peut être
un projet fadérateur le récit ne peut
pas être unique il doit s'adapter aux
réalités aux enjeux de chacun pour
atteindre les mêmes buts collectivement
construire construisant de nouveau rêves
et imaginaires préembu les suppur de
nouvelles manière d'habiter le monde il
faudra de l'énergie à tous pour dépasser
les clivages et faire advevenir un
nouveau projet de société l'enjeu
l'enjeu n'est pas la survie de notre
civilisation mais bien celle de
l'humanité alors vous allez dire c'est
un peu cucu la praline mais je crois que
c'est vraiment la question qui se pose à
nous si on veut reconstruire la France
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on a dire entre nous
qu'est-ce que on a à dire qu'est-ce que
quelqu'un qui habite au Kanta à dire à
quelqu'un qui habite à Paris qu'est-ce
qu'un expatrié à New York a envie Deir
quand est-ce qu'il a envie de revenir
dans son pays pour construire une
histoire et c'est pas des normes c'est
pas des rapports c'est ce qu'on veut
faire ensemble
Maroun même exercice on me montre la
couverture et on me lit une page euh
donc là pour voir écr ce Bouin je pense
que c'est c'est essentiel faire du fric
c'est ça ça si vous voulez tu vouz faire
du fric en écrivant des non mais que je
pense que il faut une prise de
conscience notamment parce qu'on est en
train de continuer exactement sur le
même chemin qui nous a conduit là parce
que il y a plein de slogans qu'on entend
les privatisations les externalisations
la soumission des services publics aux
impératifs de rentabilité et cetera qui
nous ont conduit là et en fait on
continue donc je voulais déjà faire un
bilan global de dire pourquoi on en est
là pourquoi est-ce que le mouvement se
poursuit alors même que les cris
d'alerte se multiplient et et qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire pour pour en sortir
l'état l'État c'est beaucoup plus large
que ce qu'on dit on a menti au français
en disant qu'on l'État c'est simplement
les formalités administratives et le
fonctionnaire qui travaille de 10h à 16h
et Cera c'est ça c'est des fantasmes
mais derrière l'état plus que 10h 16h
oui c'est ça déjà et puis l'État c'est
c'est les enseignants c'est les
infirmiers c'est leurs policiers c'est
les ingénieurs nucléaires et cetera et
quand on dit qu'on supprime des
fonctionnaires généralement c'est ceuxl
qu'on vise prof et les profs on supprime
pas comment assurer l'avenir sans prof
sans bon prof c'est c'est impossible
enfin sans l'éducation c'est impossible
on a fait passer l'éducation pour un
coup alors que c'est un investissement
c'est c'est de la folie c'est et la
santé on dit c'est c'est un coupt et
donc en fait en raisonnant comme ça on
peut rapidement devenir un un pays en
développement donc j'ai voulu aborder
monde aussi ou du c'est ça exactement
c'est plus FR et en fait si vous voulez
il y a plein de cris d'alerte sectoriel
les enseignants sur les fondement du
niveau les psychiatres français sur le
démentement la psychiatrie française sur
EDF et cetera j'ai voulu retracer
l'idéologie d'ensemble qui a conduit là
parce que moi je pense que c'est un
mouvement et une certaine élite qui a et
qui appliquant son idéologie aux
différents secteurs a conduit aux
conséquences dont on parle tu une page
tu veux un numéro de
pagezï laiss
chois laisse choisir ce qu'il ve dire
détends-toi tu as le temps tu as le
temps on pas sur le service public i
c'est la communauté qui nous finance
donc on peut prendre le temps interview
qui qui on veut souteneznous sur tipi on
en a vraiment besoin et on est on est
sans vous sans vous ça ira pas tu as
trouvé ta page oui
euh bien sûr je parle du je parle
justement de l'énergie euh sujet qu'on
affectionne avec Y brcher et on souhaite
une bonne année à Yve bonne année à Yve
euh je vous conseille de l'écouter
d'ailleurs si vous avez l'occasion c'est
un un c'est un tueur il
extraordinaire mais c'est en lien avec
un peu ce qu'on disait EDF c'est le
crime de l'Orient Express résume
anonymement à au fonctionnaire de Bercy
tout le monde est coupable dénoncé comme
coupable les visés allemandes le
dogmatisme de Bruxelles la radicalité de
certains militants écologistes ou les
luttes d'g entre dirigeants et V ça
c'est ce que j'ai expliqué comment on en
est arrivé là qu'il existe des
adversaires à la puissance énergétique
française pour des raisons financières
géopolitiques ou idéologiqu est
inévitable les véritables responsables
sont ceux qui ont laissé ces forces
centrifuge exercer une influence
profonde sur la politique énergétique
française pendant plusieurs années
dégradant l'un des piliers fondamentaux
de notre état au point que 13 millions
de Français peinent désormais à payer
leur facture d'électricité et que la
France frolle la coupure de courant
généralisé chaque hiver depuis 2017 une
tragédie dont les commanditaires n'ont
étonnamment pas à rendre de compte nous
allons nous interroger sur l'impunité
dont bénéficient certains responsables
politiques au regard des conséquences de
leur décision on n lit pas plus à mon
avis là bien motivé pour la lecture j'ai
deux dernières questions pour vous trois
livres pour notre communauté qui ont été
marquants pour vous et un conseil pour
les jeunes
génération tu peux refaire pardon TR TR
tris livres et un con pour les
générations futures après toi ah euh la
hord du contrevant d'Alain damadiio les
ville invisible d'Italo Calvino
euh la renaissance industrielle de
Pierre Musseau
et ah j'ai mangé son nom le PDG d'asso
system Bernard charless qui parle aussi
d'imaginaire dans l'industrie et un 4riè
pour la route c'est les Fabes de la
Fontaine parce que comme me disait un
ami très cher juste avant de venir il y
en a toujours une qui correspond que tu
veux
raconter et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations je vais en faire deux euh le
premier c'est venez travailler dans
l'industrie c'est vachement fun et là
vous apporterz des réponses concrètes si
jamais vous avez des problèmes
existentiels de sens l'industrie il y a
plein de défis on ne s'ennuie jamais et
la deuxième chose et je pense que
j'avais déjà dû dire ça j'ai déjà dû
dire ça à plusieurs reprises c'est soyez
vous-même soyez sincère et n'ayez pas
peur du jugement on a besoin de gens qui
s'engagent on a besoin de gens qui sont
prêts à bouger les lignes et être prêt à
bouger les lignes ça veut pas dire
manquer d'humilité et pas écouter ce que
les autres à dire on a besoin vraiment
de gens qui se mobilise en faveur de la
de la France et qui croit en des valeurs
et qui croit qu'on peut bouger même à
peu peu de personnes des montagnes
Maroun trois bouquins un conseil les
bouquins
euh je dirais
euh alors c'est des c'est c'est c'est
des essais he moi si si je veis en
bouquin il y un plein mais disons pour
pour nos sujets c'est c'est c'est
intéressant il y a un essai que j'avais
beaucoup aimé qui s'appelle c'est
messieurs de Lazar qui a été écrit par
Martine orange c'est il l'entre au cœur
de la banque d'affaires Lazar et il
retrace son histoire des années 50 à
aujourd'hui toutes les privatisations
qui ont été menées comment elle est
progressivement devenu américaine et
cetera et je pense que c'est en partie
le cœur du réacteur c'est super bien
écrit c'est extrêmement documenté elle a
fait une enquête Martine c'est voilà
elle elle est très forte et je pense que
ça montre pour ceux qui veulent pas des
trucs trop théoriques et tout les
conséquences CR de la financiarisation
de l'économie sur notre pays euh les
nouveaux maîtres du monde et ceux qui
leur résistent Jean Zigler excellent
livre perspective internationale sur le
système qui est en train de se mettrebr
gens d'ailleurs tu le connais très bien
ah ça ça c'est quelqu'un que je je
respecte
beaucoup et
enfin je t'embrasse bonne année je n pas
bon
ber ne déconcentre pas Berard
euh alors c'est c'est c'est un peu
particulier je sais pas pourquoi je
pense à celui-là mais un bouquin qui
s'appelle la concurrence des victimes
écrit par chumon j'ai oublié son son
prénom mais est très intéressant parce
que c'est une réflexion sur l'histoire
et sur la façon dont l'Europe
aujourd'hui vit de plus en plus dans le
passé euh et notamment on n'arrête pas
de recessasser une un certain passé d'un
point de vue de façon obsessionnelle
avec toutes les l'éclatement aussi des
sociétés que ça implique et je pense que
c'est une réflexion qui est qui est
assez importante après moi si je pouvais
faire librement moi j'aiété élevé dans
les BD donc ille ah les BD français je
pense qu'il y a rien de mieux pour ga
Gaston la gaffe évidemment évidemment
Gaston la gaff Spirou Lucky Luc Astérix
Charlie moibus et CEA enfin bref ça
c'est c'est ma culture personnelle
un un conseil pour les jeunes j'en
dirais deux qui sont complémentaires à
mon avis le premier c'est très prosaïque
mais spécialisez-vous ayez quelque chose
que vous savez faire et c'est ça ce qui
vous donnera l'assise pour faire tout le
reste aujourd'hui on vous dit soyez
multitasque généraliste et cetera vous
devez avoir quelque chose que vous savez
faire une valeur que vous apportez donc
spécialisez-vous mais tout en gardant
bien sûr cette cette ouverture
culturelle et le second c'est c'est
soyez libre soyez libre parce que
l'avenir c'est aussi c'est c'est vous
qui allez le créer si vous vous le
faites pas de toute façon personne ne va
le faire à votre place donc assurez vos
arrières ayez une base solide mais
ensuite soyez libre de vous engager et
n'ayez pas peur quand j'écrit le livre
on m'a dit ah mais quelqu'un d'I jeune
que toi qui s'intéresse à l'état ça n'a
aucun sens et cetera ce qui n'a aucun S
c'est de poser cette question c'est bien
le cœur du problème c'est dis ahah les
jeunes s'intéressent à leur avenir c'est
fou non c'est important et il faut qu'on
soit plusieurs à le faire Maroun il
triche il a pas 25 ans en fait il 55
cons Maroun Anaïs merci beaucoup pour
cette interview pour notre entrée on
vous recevra bien entendu une prochaine
fois ce fut fort intéressant merci
beaucoup souteneznous sur TV on vous
aime et encore bonne année bonne soirée
bonne soirée merci bonne soirée bonne
année à la commun
[Musique]